はい それではよろしくお願いします
えーと 今日の発表されているテーマについて
あの お話しさせていただきます
あの まあ人生っていうのはかなり大変ということのテーマなんですね
このテーマになったのは
まあ最近日本はまあいろいろ大変なことを次から次へと遭遇してしまっちゃって
自然災害と人為的な災害というね
まあ二つですね それから人間の頭が悪いんだからね
欲張っていて 自分のこと
人のことは全く心配しないんですから
まあ経済不振になって
世界的にいろいろあったりして
まあどちら何が起きたっても
なんか日本はダメージを受けるという
もう世界で何があったっても
まあなんか見事に日本がダメージ受けているというふうに状態になっているんですね
まあそういうことで 人生ってどういうものかというテーマになったんです
で まあ今日はお釈迦様がおっしゃった
この生きることは苦であるというテーマになります
我々は人生は辛いんだ
大変だ と私たち思っているのはちょっとおかしいんです
私たちは まあなんて幸福な人生でしょうかと
私ならもう万々歳で 抜群に幸福で幸せで
何の問題もなく生きていられるはずでしょう
という 私たちのこの何かおかしい考えがあるんです
で 子供が生まれてきたら
まあその子にはもう世界支配するぐらい
もうすごい幸福を我々は期待するんですね
しかし そうはうまくいかないんですね
それでなんだこりゃとか思ったりするんです
で 落ち込んだりするんで
この落ち込みがおかしいんですね
最初からもう調子に乗りやがっていたんですね
自分は完璧や もう何でもうまくいくんだとかね
自分の人生にはもう まあ何でしたっけ
不可能ではなくて 不幸という文字はないんだとかね
そういう調子に乗り上がってるんだから
何か自然の出来事に対してもう対応できなくなって
まあとんでもない残酷で惨めで負けてしまうんですね
ですから まあそこは生きるっていうことはどういうことかと
我々はいくらか分析して考えなくちゃいけないんですね
大体私たちはよくまあ勘違いするところっていうのは
この黄金の時代っていうことをよく聞いたことがあるんですね
まあ日本にも黄金の時代も最近もありましたね
バブルの時期はね まあそれは私が知っている黄金の時代ですけど
もっと前もあったでしょうと思いますけど
まあ西洋の黄金の時代とか
まあいろんなことを言われていますよ
で まあこの黄金の時代というのは面白いことで
全部過去なんですね 誰も今黄金の時代というふうに言わないんですね
で 過去のことなんですね
例えば中国は今黄金の時代ですけど
あの連中は今だと思ってないんです
またこれからやと思ってる
これからもう大変なことになりますけどね
で もしかするともうだから世界の国々は経済的に豊かになってはいけないというアメリカの態度があるんだから
まあ戦争を仕掛けられる可能性もありますよ
ですから まあ今は黄金の時代と思うべきなんですけど
そうは思っていない可能性もあります
だから我々も残念ですね
その時代で生まれる 生まれていることできなかったんだからね
本当はそのような時代が現実的にあったのでしょうかと
もうちょっとこの固定概念を捨てて
先入観を捨てて この歴史という嘘の学問を教えている人々の言っていることは本当なのかと
実際 黄金の時代あったのかと
その時代の人々に悩み
苦しみ 不安 怯え 脅し 搾取
それから殺しなどはなかったんですかね
この黄金の時代と我々が言っている時代ではもう盛んになっています
そういうことは だから何が黄金ですかね
黄金の時代でね あのあの
日本語で何といいますか
中国にあるグレートウォールというやつは
万里の何だらかんだらですね
あれって作るためにどれぐらい人を苦しんだんですかね？どれぐらい人々は死んじゃったんですかね
誰か誰か頭イカれてる連中
はい これ作りましょうというだけの話でしょうに
まあ日本でもね あの 何といいますか
あの世界遺産になるね
お寺やら仏像やらね もうあることあるんだけど
本当にもうみんな喜んで金あり余ってね
作りましょう すごいことだとやったのか
あるいはむちゃくちゃ苦労しながらやったのかっていうことは問題なんです
じゃあピラミッド時代って
あの連中の黄金の時代ですかね
もうどれ作ったでしょうに
それ人間でしょうに 今更これは世界の摩訶不思議やとかね
そのためにどれぐらい人々がもう苦しんで
もう死に死んでいたんですかと
で ピラミッドを発掘してみたらどうですかね
たくさん人々 あの野郎と一緒に殺されているでしょうに
それで黄金の時代 だからこの歴史学者っていうのはね
まあなんでこののこのこと嘘を言うことは学問だって言うんですかね
正しく物事を評価しないならば
どんな学問ですかと まあまあ
昨日から私は機嫌が立ってますけどね
あの 1時半でね  NHK でなんかあの原発のことについてね
初めはどうなったか どうなったかとかね
まあずっと番組があって
まあこれはもう朝までやるかどうか分からなくなって
もう 3時ぐらいでも消しちゃったんですけど
で  NHK の目的はもうこれはなんてすごいことやというふうに言いたいんだけど
まあ結局はもうデータは情報はそのままもう流しちゃうんですね
結局は それは捏造しないで
それで裏で読まれてくるストーリーというのは
まるっきり NHK さんが言いたいものじゃないんです
こんなバカが世の中に存在するもんかと思えるぐらい感想になってしまうんですね
まず物理 原子核物理学者は出ていってくださいと
これ 政治家が決めることやという感じでやったものなんですね
金ならいくらでも出してやるぞとかね
それで何の技術能力もない会社も
商社たちが入り込んで
もうあれやこれやと もうあっちこっちから
もう何といいますかね
切ったり貼ったりするような技術で
アメリカでももう技術はもう出してくれないでしょうに
まあそれで作ってあげて
で 今も原発は正しい だからヒーローを作るんですね
この 何といいますか 放射線の場合はね
まあこういうことをやりまくった
こういうことをやりましたとかね
もともとの原因は誰が作った？それはどうでもいいんです
自分が被爆しながら人々を助けてあげたですねとかね
なんてヒーローでしょうかとかね
いまだにヒーローストーリー作ってなるんですね
だからもうやっぱり機嫌が悪くなりますよ
こんな入りくどい世界でね
バブルがはじけた時でも
これで日本はものすごいどん底に落としたのは誰ですか？と全然調べてないんです
次にもまたその連中に日本の将来を委託しちゃったんです
だからこの これは日本だけの
私は日本にいるんだから日本のデータ出しますけど
まあいつだってそういうことなんで
世の中っていうのは 人類のことを心配するっていうことは全くないんですね
そこで あの 異常欲異常怒りがない
精神的に落ち着き落ち着いている
寿命は桁違い 長い 退屈を感じる以外
病気にかからない 平和な黄金の時代の物語は仏教にもあります
黄金の時代とは言わないんですけど
もう時々時期があるんだよというふうに
まあストーリー 物語がありますけど
仏教がイメージする物語の場合は
寿命はもう軽々と 1万4000ですよ
若い時も だから少年中年老人だから
1万4000が 1万4000
1万4000年になりますからね
まあちょっと足したらどれぐらいになるかよくわかりませんだけどね
8万4000のミスですね
まあそれぐらい寿命が長いんだと
人間 人間 しかし その理由は欲と怒りがないんだ
心穏やかで まあ少々微妙にね
日常に必要な欲がありますけど
ご飯食べなくちゃとかね
まあ子供を可愛がってあげなくちゃとかね
まあその程度の欲がありますけど
子供はちょっと変なことをやったら
これは何をやっているのかとかね
いい加減にしろよと叱ったりしなくちゃいけないしね
その程度の欲と怒りがあるんですけど
異常欲 異常怒りがないんだと
だから仏教がイメージする黄金の時代っていうのは
人間が精神的に豊かっていうことです
だから人殺しはありえないでしょ
搾取なんかありえないでしょ
それで心がものすごい清らかで健康ですから
肉体は長生きしますよと
しかし 彼らには病気がありますよと
退屈になるんです そんな長生きしちゃうとね
まあ現代で言えば薄ですね
ああ 退屈やというふうなことはあるんだと
それ以外病気がない くしゃみもない
で そこで人殺しはないし
怒りがないでしょ  そういう社会を築くことができれば
それが文字通りの黄金の時代なんですよ
万里の長城を作ったんだからね
あれはもう悲しみの怯えの苦しみの時代なんです
どこかの国で 例えば仏教を信仰している場合はね
もう伝染病で もうもう干ばつで
もう人々は死にかけていると
ではでっかい仏像を作りましょうよと
で 阿弥陀様に もう何様でもいいんですけど
どんな如来様にも願をかけて
国がまた豊かになりますようにとかね
まあこれって何の象徴ですか？人間の嘆きの悲しみの象徴になっちゃうでしょうに
だから私は批判を受けるかもしれませんだけど
なんでもう世界文化遺産に対して悪口言うのかと
別に作品が まあまあまあまあいいんじゃないんですかと思いますけど
今更は作れませんよとかね
まあそれはもう考古学的に私も大事にするべきやと思いますけど
しかし その中では感動物語はありません
それだけ覚えておいてください
で 原発はもう壊れちゃってね
もう永遠に日本が大変な目になったんですけど
これが置いておいて感動物語を作るんですね
毎日テレビ番組見ると
まあ子供たちはどのように頑張って学校に行っているんでしょうかとか
じゃあみんなもう何て言いますか
放射線をあれ測る あれをみんな持ってますよとか
どうですかとか 頑張っているんだ
みんなとかね 感動物語作るんであって
この問題解決してるっていうことはないでしょうに
こんなアホなことするべきかと
今日もこの何金っていうんですか
交付金でしたっけ？まあそういう地方で
まあそのお金で政府からね
もらって 原発を作ることでむちゃくちゃ金儲かって
まあそれで学校を作ったり
いろいろ遊ぶところを作ったりして遊んでいるんだっていう
それで原発を起動しないと
もうその地方が大変だと
だから地方の人々にふざけるために
まあまた原発を起動させなくちゃいけないんですね
そんなに金がなくても何か悪いんですかね
毎日食べるものがあれば
病気になったら治療を受けるぐらいの用意ができていればね
なんで地方でもばっかでっかいビルが必要ですかね
遊びたければいくらでも原っぱあるでしょうに
なんでビルの中でテニスやらなくちゃあかんですかね
東京ではビルの中でテニスやったり
野球やったりするのは構わないんだけど
しかしそんなことをもうむちゃくちゃな
もう妄想的なイメージを作ってやっても
金がないんだから そういうことで
もう国のお金 国のお金って誰のお金ですかね
国民のお金でしょうに
政治家にそんな国民のお金を好き勝手に使うっていうことはとんでもない泥棒でしょ
私たちの間でばらまきしましょうよとかね
何の重みも何の痛みも感じませんね
だから私は仏教徒から見れば
国のお金っていうのは 1円であってもものすごい重みを感じるべきなんですね
この 1円が全国民の 1円なんです
1円盗んだら 日本人口今どれぐらいでしたっけ？何億
1億2600万1億 2600万人の盗んだことになるんですよ
私のポケットから 1万円盗んでも
一人の人間に泥棒を買ったことになるんです
額は 1万円かもしれませんよ
だから一人の人間に損害を与えたんだから
これは二人で話し合ってなんとかなります
申し訳ないことをしましたと
じゃあ 1万円盗んだんだから
まあ罰金としてあなたに 2万円払いますと
で 弁償しますという何とかできますから
日本国民の 1円盗んだらどうなるんですかね
どうやって国民に弁償するんですかね
それは ですから このこのサンガの財産と国の財産っていうのは
それ大変なもんなんです
個人のものじゃないんですよ
もうとんでもない 真剣に気をつけて
それは使わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
それで無駄遣いやめましょうと言ったら
絶対政府を倒してやるぞという調子になっちゃうんです
何言うのかと  そういう世界ですから
で あの黄金の時代について
まあちょっと最近 喋りすぎですね
あの で 言いたいのは お釈迦様
仏教の方々は考えた黄金の時代だったら頑張った方がいいんです
そういう黄金の時代を作るために
欲と怒りのない世界 その結果として
から肉体も心も健康で
誰も誰を殺害しない いじめない世界
それが黄金の世界なんです
ですから このそんな世界はなかったということにしましょう
私の勝手な主観的な考えかもしれませんだけど
こう ここら辺に空いてます
で 私が言いたいポイントは
このローマの時代とかね
ヨーロッパの時代とかね
で いろいろありますけど
黄金の時代とかね なんとかなんとか言いますけど
その時も人間が怯えて
貧困の問題があって 病気になったらどうしようもなくなって
あまりにも抑えられれて
自由はひとかけらもなく苦しんでいたんです
ギリシア人の黄金の時代で
もう人を捕まえてライオンと戦わせる時代でしたからね
あんなのを豊かするんですかね
それでスポーツが始まったと
同じアホな連中は世界に巻き込まれて
みんな道連れにして倒れよう倒れようとしてるでしょうに
ギリシアが 何ですか あの態度は
嘘ばっかし言いやがって
英雄からいっぱい借金取っちゃって
国債作ったりして あれで遊んじゃったんです
国を開発するべきところ
しっかりした経済対策を取るべきところは
もう遊ぶところを作るんですね
で 誰も使わない  日本もそういうことをやってましたけどね
それでその好きがみんな受けなくちゃかっていうのはどういうことですかね
だからもういつだってこの世の中はそんなもので
不公平で もう生きづらい世界なんです
何の管理能力もないんだったら
管理者のトップになる
金のからくりできなかったら
もう経済世界のトップになるという世界なんです
原発作るなれば 専門家の意見は聞くないこと
あいつら反対するんだからと
これで大変ないい世界が出来上がっちゃいます
それから今更あれやこれやと文句言ったってもね
それで仏教から言うのは
誰か犯人見つけてそいつをやっつけるだけということは答えじゃないんですよ
今 リビアのガダフィを殺しちゃったんですね
40年間も独裁政権やっていたんだとか
あれやこれやとかね あの人たち40年間もやっていたのは
もう40年間国民がもう黙っていたんだからね
私はそれなりにいろいろ頑張ったと思いますよ
逆に だから独裁なんですけど
まあしょうがないと まあそこはもう歳も取って
もう頭も悪くなっちゃって
どうにもならなくなったところで
追い出されたっても大したことはないんです
もう どうせボロボロ老人ですから
あの人は はい それでガダフィを殺しました
これからリビアには豊かさと平和が訪れると思う
とんでもない これから殺し合いやるんだから
あのイスラム厳密主義でやらなくちゃいけない
いえいえ もうちょっと緩やかな方がいいやとかね
じゃあ殺し合いましょうと
そんなことなんですね
いつだってこの問題は
ガダフィ殺したんだからといって
問題は解決しないんです
日本の政府を批判したんだからといって
日本の問題は解決しないんです
もともと人間っていうのはもともとおかしいんです
だから これが仏教は言っているところなんです
お前悪い お前悪いじゃないんです
我々はもともと欠陥だらけだと
だからみんな欠陥だらけだったら
じゃああなたにお願いしますということになりたたないんです
ついでに言いますけど
人間というのは神にお祈りするでしょうに
神に委託する 何かしてくださいと
お釈迦様はそれにもからかって悪口を言うんです
神どもたちも貪瞋痴で怯えるものやと
そちらも権力争いやら
あれやこれやとある世界やと
自分も怯えている人が人なのに
また私の恐怖感を何とかしてください
頼んだて これは無意味やと
やめなさい そんなのはと
神に祈ることを いうふうなもう立場なんですよ
仏教は だから一切怯えをなくした仏法僧に頼ったらどうですかと
しかし 仏法僧を拝むということじゃなくて
私のようなものすごい厳しい聞きたくない言葉を聞いて
心をぐるっと もう組み立て組み立て直さないと
自分の足で立てないと
で お願いします お願いしますという人生はダメなんです
では今日はいかがでしょうか
という人生でなければダメなんです
だから仏法僧に頼ると
もう叩き直すんです 人間の心を
で それで私は異端者やと思ってますけど
本当は私は正統派なんです
仏教の 私がずっと調べて
お釈迦様が喋ったこの口調とかね
お釈迦様が使った手段とかね
表現力とか言葉の使いとかね
まあ論理性とかね 全部調べて
そこは再現してみようかなと
だから皆様 日常聞いている仏教の説法とはものすごい違うんです
で それで異端者と思っちゃっても
お釈迦様の立場から見ればもう正統派なんです
じゃあ話に入ります 夢
希望と現実 妄想工場の妄想工場の製品なので
限りなく大量生産できます
何を？夢と希望はいくらでも作れますよ
しかし 現実できるのは一億分の1にも足らないわずかな夢です
実現できるのは いくらでも夢がありますよ
いくらでも作れます 限りなく
しかし 実現できるのかと
一つも 私は一億分じゃなくて
これ一兆分ってした方がいいんです
それでもちょっとね 一日中どれぐらい夢作るんですかね
日常生活の中で 想定外
そんなはずではなかった
期待が外れた うまくいかなかった
いかないなど 悩みながら生きてるんです
誰に聞いたって まあまあ
なんとかあんまりうまくいかないね
この頃は とかね そればっかりでしょうね
誰も明るい言葉持ってないでしょうね
みんな嘆いてるんです
会社は大変だとか あれやこれやとかしゃべると全部もう泣き声
もう日本ではもしかすると 1ヶ月ぐらい
もうもうもうもう毎日のように新しい曲出してるでしょ
大量に 一つも明るい歌がないんです
全部泣いてるんです あなたのこと欲しいやとかね
歌一曲けないんですよ
喜んで手をたたいて喜べるような歌一つもないんです
かなり人気ある 前でしたっけ？上を向いて歩こうよと
それで足をこけて死んでしまうよとかね
で やっぱりあれはいくらか人間を応援する歌なんですけど
結局は悲しい曲を歌う時は気分がいいんですね
だから東北に行ったらみんなもう聞き飽きちゃうほどあの歌を聴いてると思いますよ
だって日本のプロの人々はみんな行くでしょ
音楽関係の一流の歌手たちがみんな何のことなく行って
まあ歌って 何か帰ればみんなあれを歌うんですね
だから自分の持ち歌を歌って帰ればいいのに
じゃあみんなで合唱しましょうということでね
まあどうでもいいことなんですけど
私が言いたいのは そういう個人的な局部的な攻撃ではなくて
一般的なことを言いたいんですけど
人間の口から 嘆きの声しかわめきの声しか
なんで出てこないんですかね
あれが悪い これが悪いという話しか出てこないでしょうね
この原因はどこにあるのかというと
この夢の問題なんです
夢と現実のこの隔たりなんです
どんな人間も宇宙よりバカでかい夢をいっぱい持ってるんです
夢の大きさを見れば 宇宙も足りませんよ
だって妄想工場ですからね
いくらでも潰れます しかし
現実と合わせてみると
まあ落ち込むこと切りがないんです
これぐらい夢あったんだけど
これしかないんだと だからお腹いっぱいごちそうを食べようと思ったところで
あのご飯 1粒だけ これも半分
米の 1粒の半分 はい どうぞとでっかい皿に入れてくれるような感じなんです
で これ取りに取れないでしょうに
1粒でも食べられないで
あまりも小さくて喉を通らないんで
あれは口の中で溶けて終わっちゃいます
これも半分だったらどうしますか
お腹いっぱいごちそう食べたいぐらい夢があるんだけど
口に入るのはこの米 1粒の半分という程度なんです
だったら泣くしかないでしょう
失望に陥るしかないでしょう
精神的悩みの親は夢と希望なんです
我々にある精神的な悩み
ここは夢が親です 夢と希望
いわゆる妄想ですね あればいくらでも精神的には悩みます
精神的に悩めるならば
理性いったからもないんです
その人々に支配されているんです
人間には夢がないと活発に生きていられない
生きられないという持病があります
これって病気です 夢がないと動けないんですね
相当な病気なんです 私は夢っていうのはまるっきりないんです
時々あなたのどうですかね
どういう風な計画 将来どう考えているのかと聞かれたっても
どう答えればいいかと
私ははっきり何にもないんだと
私はそんな頭が良くないんだと
今日のこと以外は考えられませんよと
だから極限にバカで生きてますよという答えになるんです
こんな頭が良くない 明日の明後日のことも想像もできん
もう頭にインプットしないんです
しかし 人間というのはそうじゃなくて
明日 明後日 来年 再来年
100年後までも計画あった方がもう元気で活発で生きていられると思っているんです
これが病気以外何でもないんです
私は最初に説法するときはよく質問されたんですよ
あなた 夢とか希望とかね
こんなの否定しますけどね
人間にとってすごいありがたいことではないかと
その時も私は喋り出した時だから
まあ向こうの方がね ちょっと力強いし
だからこの将棋っていうのはやり方があるんだからね
で 向こうの方が強烈に攻撃する時は守りに入るんです
それから包囲して全部潰しちゃうんです
守りに入ると 向こうは調子に乗って攻撃に来るんです
攻撃に来たら何のことなく包囲できます
ですから まあそう言われたことってあるんですね
それで私はやっぱりこれは断言に否定しちゃったらまずいし
まあどう答えればいいかとかね
しかし今日は答えます
人間というのは病気です
夢と希望 願望 何かなければ
動けなくなっちゃうんです
しかし 夢と現実を比較すると
必ず悩み 苦しみ 落ち込み
怒り 憎しみ 失望などで病む羽目になります
活発に生かしてくれるはずの夢が生きる力を蝕むんです
そこで我々は夢と希望があれば活発になるぞと元気いっぱい生きられる
そうと思うでしょう しかし
夢と希望があればあるほど失望するんですね
うまくいかないんですね
競争しなくちゃいけないんですよ
で 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみが出てくるんです
とんでもない精神的な病気がいっぱいかかってきて
もう怒り 生きる力が蝕んで終わってしまいます
このカラクリを理解してほしいんです
だから 夢と希望があって生きてみるぞと言ったら
とてつもない危険なことなんです
貪瞋痴は炎に例えられています
でお釈迦様がもう我々は欲があって
怒りがあって 無知があって頑張っているんです
いろんな欲しいものがあって
希望があって 潰したいライバルがいて
これで元気になっちゃいます
日本の会社にもね 何としてでも中国を倒さなくちゃあかんさ
教えたらみんな喜んで頑張ると思いますよ
中国人にできないいろんな品物を開発しようではないかとかね
やっぱり怒りの炎をつけてあげないと
火をつけないともう動かないんです
だから我々は夢と希望っていうのは
この貪瞋痴のことで お釈迦様がそれはもう炎だと思いますよと
で 説かれています はい
それでは人生の苦しみって何ですか？と
苦っていうのは命のことなんです
生命は生老病死で成り立っている
生老病死はなくなると
命も生きることも輪廻も成り立ちません
今日の今のポイントは相当難しいんです
このまま暗記するしかないんです
苦は命です 苦しみはなくしたいでしょ
じゃあ自殺してください
苦は命です なくすものじゃないんです
そこで命っていうのは
生老病死という四つの働きで成り立っているんです
で これ お釈迦様っていうのはいつも謎謎で
もう我々に謎を出しますからね
お釈迦様は人間の頭がもうビシビシと働いてほしいんです
だからストレートで語られているように
ちょこっと謎を見せてするんです
そこで生老病死で 我々にとっては何だ知ってますよと
だって生まれることでしょ
赤ちゃんとかね まあ年取ることをおじいさんとかね
病気もわかって この間おばあちゃんがね
ちょっとお腹を壊して病気になったとかね
じゃあ死 これはもうおじいさんのもうもう一人おじいさんが亡くなったんだと
お兄さんがね 葬式に私たちも行きましたよと
それ生老病死やと思いますかね
それだったら まあ私も若いし
元気であるしね 全然苦しみがないんですね
私は私のことじゃないんです
まあ例えば二十歳から三十代までの人
四十代までのね 何の生老病死ですかね
あの連中はうるさくて
あまりにも元気でね ぶん殴ってやりたいぐらいでしょうに
元気がありすぎちゃって
俺 生老病死の苦しみあるわけないでしょ
そこはお釈迦様の謎なんですね
これは偉大なる真理ですからね
聖なる真理ですからね
これ 誰でも考えている生老病死ではありません
何かあるはずなんです
ですから ちょっと難しいんです
では 一応説明します わからなかったら居眠りしてください
もうほかやり方法ないんです
命は細胞一個だとしましょう
細胞一個の命もありますね
あの単細胞のさんにも生老病死があるんです
じゃあ単細胞様がどんな生老病死ですかね
風邪でも引く 細胞一個だから風邪引かんでしょう
お腹も壊さない お腹ないんだからね
高血圧になるわけないでしょ
血液もないんだから だったら単細胞さんにはね
生老病死がないでしょ
しかし あるんです この単細胞もすーっと自分が動いて体を維持しなくちゃいけないんです
これは生なんですよ 生まれることなんです
だからアメーバも栄養をとっているんです
とって体を作っているんです
でないと命はないんです
それで我々も瞬間も休むことなく
我々の体が栄養をとって復活させているんです
体を これ 瞬間も休むことできんです
この 1 日3食やっていうのはね
これは冗談です 瞬間も栄養を取らない瞬間ないんです
ずっと栄養をとっているんです
品物のエネルギーを入れているんです
これで我々の体もいつでも小の状態でいるんです
単細胞も同じです 老って何ですかね
また細胞が動いているでしょ
それで栄養を取った途端
細胞は年取ってますよ
で 動かしちゃうということが
もう有効期限が短くなるということなんです
使っちゃうとそうなりますよ
どんな品物でも ですから
我々は栄養を取るということは体を使っていることなんです
栄養をとって その栄養を使うということも体を使っていることなんです
それが老いることなんです
賞味期限も有効期限も短くなるんです
だから 細胞一個にはちゃんと有効期限というのはあるんです
単細胞さんにはもうすごいわかりやすいんだけど
我々はいろんな細胞を持ってますから
有効期限はバラバラなんですね
皮膚の細胞の有効期限と骨の細胞の有効期限はちょっとバラバラで
心臓細胞はまた寿命が変わっていて
脳細胞はまた違うしね
有効期限バラバラであっても
年取ることは取ります
ですから 細胞一個が消費するも老いるずつであります
次のポイント 病 栄養を取らなかったらどうなるんですかね
細胞が成り立たないんです
酸素を入れなかったら成り立たないんです
このままではダメなんです
死んじゃいます しかし
手当てすれば死ぬことを避けられます
病気の定義はそれなんです
このままでは死にます
手当てするとなんとかなります
ですから 仏教では あのお腹が空くことも病気だというんです
皆様はお腹が空くことは元気の証拠だと思っているでしょ
はい だから誰の意見？私はお釈迦様の意見正しいと思います
お腹が空くことは病気なんです
なぜかというと 何かしなかったら死にます
しかし お腹が空いても人は死なない
何か食べればいいでしょ
だから食べるものは薬になります
その定義でいかなくちゃいけないんです
この高血圧で病気とかね
糖尿病とかね そんなどうでもいいことを言うんじゃないんです
そんなのはそんなに大げさな病気じゃないんです
みんなにあるわけでもないし
アメーバはならないしね
人間に罹っている病気一つにもならんだからね
健康そのもの しかし ブッダが病気っていうのは
手当するならばなんとかなります
手当しないと まあさようならと
いう厳しい条件定義で病を定義するんです
だからアメーバさんも病気です
我々もとんでもない細胞たくさん一応何兆ぐらい持ってるでしょ
それぐらい病気持ってます
手当しなきゃ そういうわけで
命っていうのは生じつ
生じつつ老いるつつ病もそれもつっつなんです
常に病 病んでいる 病みつつなんです
それで壊れます いくら手当したっても
こんな曖昧で中途半端で成り立たない不確定の不安定の
この細胞が永遠になるわけないでしょう
で 壊れるんです だからご飯食べたっていうこともある程度で死んだっていうことなんです
呼吸したっていうことは
ある程度であんた死んじゃったよと
だって死ぬまで何回呼吸するのかと
回数は決まってます ここで一回やっちゃったら
それ終わっちゃうでしょうに
だから死つつなんです
この生老病死という 4種類の働きが命なんです
だからおじいさんが老でおばあさんが病でとか
そんな程度じゃないんです
赤ちゃんがもう生で生まれちゃったんだからとかね
これはお釈迦様が我々にかけた謎なんです
だからブッダの単語っていうのは
あえて素朴で一般的なんです
決してややこしい難しい専門用語は使いません
ですから 生老病死とは戦えません
これ 命です 対立することもできません
現象的な生老病死を一時的に制御することはありますが
生老病死である命と戦えると戦えると勘違いしないことです
現象的な生老病死ね  頭が痛くなったとかね
風邪が引きましたとかね
まあそれとは戦えますよ
これ 本物の病気じゃないんです
何か新しい何かね 体に新しいこと出てきたら
これはなんとかなります
で 戦えません はい それで私はあの経典ではない単語なんですけど
もう一つ単語 2つ考えちゃったんです
一つは現実苦 前のページで紹介した生老病死は現実苦なんです
現実にあるものなんです
命と別にあるわけじゃなくて
命が生老病死です だから命が苦です
私は生きてるんだっていうことは
苦があるんだっていう意味なんです
苦以外何ともないんです
ドゥッカエーワヒサンボーティドゥッカンテティヴェーティチャという風に教えられてます
これ あんまり使わないブッダの言葉なんです
これは経典にあるのは
ある尼さんがね もう誰かにからかわれちゃって
マーラさんにね 女たちがね
家で休んだ方がいいでしょ
何修行っていうの？そしたらマーラさんにね
一つ言葉を言ったんですよ
で 彼女は阿羅漢でしたからね
本当のこと知っていてんだから
何言うのかと 生まれるのもドゥッカであって
あるのもドゥッカであって
消えるのもドゥッカだよと
こちらでこの人とか生命とか
そんなのはないんだよと
そういうことで 生老病死が苦です
命が苦です ここで私がいるんだということは
ここに苦があるんだということなんです
私は堂々と現実的にいるでしょ
ですから 堂々と現実的に苦があるんです
それは現実苦なんです
じゃあどうしますか？私がいること
苦だったら皆さん私を殺す
まあ殺したい気持ちはわかりますけど
もう実行できんでしょう
そんなことやったっても
何の問題にも解決にはなりませんね
ですから それは現実です
この現象は人間に太刀打ちできないので
感化すがいなんです ですから
この現実苦を感化すがいだと思ってください
何とかして手当てしようと思わないでください
しかし 感覚が苦であると
もう一つの現実苦があるんです
はい 前はどうでもいい
放っておいてください
生老病死のこと 2番目あります
感覚がこうなんですよ
例えば立っている感覚がありますよ
これ 私も1時間ぐらい立っていると相当苦しくなっちゃうんです 1
時間経つと苦しくなったっていうことは 1
秒1秒苦しみが足していったっていうことなんです
そこが耐えられる 耐えられないというところだけです
だから耐えられる苦しみは
我々は苦しみじゃないと思っているんです
立った瞬間から苦が生まれるんです
これ 1時間 2時間になってくると
耐えられないということになるだけ
こういう風に 例えば手を上げたら何のことないと思っちゃうでしょ
じゃあ3分ぐらいこういうふうにしておけば
相当耐えられないんですね
苦しくなるんですね ですから
この体の場合は感覚が空なんです
目の感覚もこうなんです
何かじっと見ていると
耐えられないんです  大体 1 分も一つのものを見ていることはできないんです
体よりも目の方が厳しいんです
皆さんは 1 分何か見ているようなつもりでしょう
でも まぶたはパチパチパチパチと閉じて見ないことにしているんです
ですから セロハンテープで目を瞼を開けて
両目も開けて時計を回して 1 分間見ていてください
楽しくなりますよ だって皆様そう思ってるでしょう
目があるんだだから映画も見られるし
舞台劇場も見られるし
美しい絵画も見られるでしょうね
花も見られるし 最近だったら何て言ったっけ？紅葉も見られるしね
なんてすごいことですかね
同時になんて馬鹿ですかと私が言いたいんですね
瞬間瞬間変わらないと耐えられませんよ
あの苦しみには だから紅葉を見ようと思って京都にいらっしゃるならば
京都駅で降りたところでさっさっとセロハンテープで
これは瞬間でも目閉じてね
見ないことにしてはいけませんよと
全部見てやるぞと 見られるもんかと
そうすると何も見えなくなっちゃいますよ
あまりも苦しくて そういうことで
正しく調べれば感覚が苦です
耳の感覚も苦です ベロの感覚も苦です
鼻の感覚も苦です で 感覚がないと死んでるんです
私は感覚があるんだから立ってるんです
感覚があるんだから歩けるんです
感覚があるんだから座れるんです
感覚があるんだからお腹がすいたとわかるんです
感覚があるんだからご飯食べられます
感覚があるんだから あ
満腹になったとわかります
ということは 命をつかさどってつかさどっているパワーがエネルギーが感覚なんです
生かされている神様が感覚です
しかし この神様は苦そのものです
苦でないとうまくいかないんです
例えば立っていると苦ではなく楽が生まれたとしましょう
ああ 楽しいと  1 分立っていると 1 分楽しくて
2 分立っていると 2 分楽しくて
そうなっちゃうと 私は永久的に座れなくなっちゃうんです
だって 立っていればいるほど楽しいでしょう
あの ちょっとこっちおいでと人が頼んでも
嫌だと言うんです 俺は立ってるんだよと
だって立っていること楽しいんだから
もしご飯食べるとおいしくて楽しいんだったら
大変なことになります
やめられなくなります
ご飯 1口食べて  吾輩は幸せやとかね
では 2口食べると吾輩は 2回幸せやでしょ
で  100口ぐらい食べれば
もし食べるたびに楽しみが生まれてくるならば
我々はもうやめることできなくなっちゃうんです
これで命が成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
だから 1口食べても 美味しいと感じても
あれは勘違いで苦しみを感じているんです
だから 適当なところで
ほどほどのところで食べることをやめます
立っていても 適当な時間でほどほどの時間で座れます
感覚が苦だから車に気をつける
感覚が苦だから赤信号を渡ろうとしないんです
感覚は苦だから 踏切をくぐって向こうに行こうとはしないんです
そういうことで 感覚が苦という現実があります
これも現実です 科学的です
いくらでも証明できます
はい 感覚を苦楽 不苦楽として認識するので
苦を避けて楽を目指すことで生きています
これで人間には問題があって
感覚というのは賛成だろうと言うんです
だって苦しい時もあるし
楽しい時もあるし どちらでもない時がありますよと
みんなそう思ってるんだから
お釈迦様その単語を使いますけど
しかし これなぞなぞで
別なところで謎に応えていますよ
感じるものはすべて苦に属しますよと
しかし それはあまり派手に言わないんです
勉強する我々は このお釈迦様の謎を解かなくちゃいけないんです
そこで自分で解いたところで
経典を読むとドカンと答えが見つかるんですよ
その時はもう感動します
我ながらなかなか大したもんやと
で 感動します 仏典での大体もうどこかでちょこっとちょこっと謎が置いておくんです
これ解読すると面白いんですよ
で どうしても解読できなくて
ぐちゃぐちゃ苦労すると
まあ答えもあります はい
そういうことで 私たちにとっては
人生にはまあ苦しみもあれば楽しみもある
まあどちらでもないものもあるという感覚は３種類になるんです
これで人間が３種類に分けたんだから
この感覚をどうするのかというと
苦の感覚を追い出しちゃって
楽の感覚が欲しいと思って生きているんです
これも現実です 苦の変化が楽だと誤解する
生きるとは すでに歩くを別な苦に変えることです
生きるということは すでに歩く
別な苦に変える 立っている時の苦しみを座る苦しみに変えるんです
だから座った瞬間で気持ちいいと思っちゃいます
しかし 30分ぐらい座っていると
やっぱり腰が痛いと言うんです
だから別な苦に変わっちゃったんです
空腹の苦は 満腹の苦で置き換えるんです
この変換するときは楽しいと思っちゃうんです
変換が終わったら楽しくはないんです
元素は無常なので 苦は当然生滅の変化をしています
だから苦しむも生滅変化しています
しかし 私たちにそれで満足できないんです
だから すーっと感覚は変化しているんです
だから放っておけばいいんですけど
これではちょっと満足できないんです
意図的に苦を変えることに頑張っています
意図的に変えようとするんです
もうどうしても苦は変わっている
例えば 寒い時 外に出たら寒いでしょう
寒いという苦しい感覚はあるんです
あのすーっとその感覚は変化しているんです
だから放っておけばいいんです
これはダメです あー寒いんだから何かホッカイロでもつけなくちゃ
もう一つ上着を着なくちゃとかね
じゃあ家の中に走っちゃって
もうもうストーブつけなくちゃというふうに
私たちは意図的に感覚を変えるんです
これがもう頑張っているという意味なんですね
一生懸命で生きるとは
一生懸命に苦を別な苦に変えることなんです
だから 一生懸命人が生きるということは
一生懸命苦を別な苦に置き換えているんです
ゴミは別なゴミに入れ替えているんです
それが素晴らしいです
人生です はい 次 2番目
非現実苦 一は現実苦 あの感覚は本当にマジで苦しみですよ
現実です それが 誰かに殴られたらね
気分がいいわけじゃないんです
あれ マジ痛いんです 誰にだって
だからそれは現実苦なんです
はい 非現実苦っていうのは
まあ妄想苦とも構わないんですね
苦を変えると楽になるのだという推測が妄想の起爆剤になります
私たちは あ この苦しみは変えれば楽になるだろうという妄想があるんです
推測があるんです 今苦しいんだけど
まあそろそろ経済状況良くなったら
まあ収入がうまくいくだろうって推測するんです
今 円高で日本は大変だよと
まあそろそろまあそこはなんとかなるだろうと推測するんです
それでいい気分になるんですけど
なりませんよ だって手を打ってないんだから
自動的に円安く円安になりますから
はい 待ちましょうと 日本の日銀の総裁やら政府のお偉い方々やら
経済世界のお偉い方々は手を組んでます
という素晴らしいことをやっているんです
私もいやになってますよ
もう 30年も日本にいたんだから
この日本の強いところは手を組んで待つということなんです
私がイライラする 動けと
失敗しようが成功よ そんなのどうでもいいんだからね
動けというのが私の哲学なんです
これはあまり日本文化では好きじゃないみたい
だいたい日本 人間っていうのは変化が嫌なんですね
すごい保守主義なんです
現状維持が好きなんです
ということは能力ないんです
はい このままで変わらないでいてほしいという
この保守主義者たちですよ
保守主義っていうのは自然法則ではないんです
自然は変化しているんです
我々は変化とともに激しく変化しないと
潰されます だから仏教は進歩主義なんです
進歩主義を語っているんです
動けと言っているんです
止まるなかれと あなた勝手に止まっても止まれませんよと
止まったらダラッと壊れるだけ
止まりはないんです はい
そういうことで この 動かなくちゃいけないんですけど
私たちが保守主義者たちで現状維持が欲しくて
過去に戻りたくて ありえないんだけどね
で 計画立てるんです だからもういい加減なんですよ
計画っていうのは 将来に対する変化でなければいけないのに
はい それで私たちは まあ子供は真面目に勉強してくれれば
私には悩むことがないんだと
子供は大学受験すれば
まあ本当にもう荷物下ろしたような感じで自分が安らぎになるよとか
いろんなことを言ってますよ
仕事をする方々はもうちょっと3万円ぐらい給料上がったら大丈夫やと奥さんに聞いたら
まあ3万円ぐらいあったらなんとかからくりできますよと
それだったら私も月々3万余分にと思っちゃいますよ
では問題は 3万円給料上がっちゃうと
奥さんは6万円の計画はとっくに組んでいるんです
あるいは子供が大きくなっちゃって
前よりは金かかるようになってるんです
奥さんが計画立たなくても
どうにもならん これが
はい それで私たちはこれこれがなんとかすればなんとかなるだろうという推測あるんですよ
この推測でいかにものすごく妄想するんです
みんな女性の方々もね
もう鼻がもうちょっと4ミリ長かったら私も売れるぞとかね
それで8ミリ伸ばったって
もうもう売れない女 売れないんですよ
もう性格ですからね 性格悪いんだから
ね で もうちょっと10キロ痩せれば
あのモデルさんの服を着られますと
そうするとかっこいいんだと着る人
自称たちがいますけど
私にはカカシに服を着させたように見えるんですね
だってあれ スマートの体じゃなくて
無理をして無理をしてカカシになってるんですよ
だから命がないんです
体の中で まあお化けになってるんですね
まあ大体4割ぐらい これで服を着させちゃうと
なおさら気持ち悪くなるんです
まあしかし まあ私たちはそういうふうにいろんなことを考えて
これさえあれば これさえあれば
これさえあれば あるいはこれさえなければ
これさえなければというふうに考えているんですね
これで妄想が生まれるんです
これ推測です で 自分の過去の人生をチェックしてください
これさえなければと思ったことがなくなったこと
いくらでもあるでしょ
これさえあればと思ったことはいくらでもあるでしょ
あればと思ったことはあったと
本当に問題解決したんですかと
過去の人生を見てみると
これさえなければということは当然なくなっていくんです
これさえあればと思ったものは
当然自分に返ってくるんです
では問題解決したんですかと
これで過去のデータでスタディしないんです
それを忘れちゃって また将来を見て
これさえあれば これさえなければということで生きているんです
無制限の期待 希望 願望
夢 計画 企画などが頭の中で現れるんです
それで頭の中であらゆる計画
企画 希望 願望は無制限に現れてくるんです
それと現実は一致しないので
無制限の精神苦が現れてくるんです
これが非現実苦なんです
余計に苦しみを作るんです
本当はないんですけど
自分で作るんです だからバカなところですよ
生きることが苦なのに
また作る必要ないでしょ
人間が新しく あの 意図的に新しい苦しみを作るんです
ね 砂漠の熱は耐えられないと
何でしたっけ？炭火の穴に飛び込むことをやってます
これは仏教経典に出てくる例えなんですよ
でっかい洞穴があって
その中で炭をね いっぱい入れて燃やしておくんです
それで炎がなくなって
ものすごい熱が出ていると
そこで飛び込むと それで人がもう砂漠で
まあこんな暑くてね 嫌だ
こんな暑さはとか 砂漠は暑いに決まってますけどね
俺がこの穴に飛び込むそうと
砂漠の暑さはほら 邪魔見ろよと
どうなるんですかね だから我々に
にとっては 障老病死の苦があるんです
砂漠にいるんです それに非現実的な人為的な苦を作っているんです
炭火の中に飛び込むんです
なくせる非現実 非現実苦
これがなくせます それでわかりますか？ 2つありますね
放っておく苦 もう太刀打ちできない苦があって
勝手に作った苦をなくしてくださいと
これなくせます 妄想ではなく
現実的な思考を駆使して生きるならば
無制限の精神苦がなくなるんですよ
至って簡単です アホな妄想をやめて
まあ現実的なことを考えて軽く生きてみれば
例えば被害があったと
日本に 100人も起こらない被害であると
だから別に現実を見て
見回りを見て 今日はどうすればいいかと
考えれば楽でしょうね
ああ 家がなくなった 子供は 3人も亡くなった
おじいさんも亡くなったとかね
工場が流されましたとか
どうしよう これからどうしようとかね
これが余計な苦なんです
仕事した工場が流されちゃったらまた戻ってこないでしょ
放っておけど そんなことは
手の打ちようもないでしょうね
しかし 頭の中でやっぱり前と同じく仕事をしたいとかね
前と同じで家族で仲良く生活したいとかね
住み慣れた家で家ないんですけど
跡形も 住みたいが 住みたいということが入ってくると
これはお化けのように人を徹底的に苦しめるんです
あの現実苦それほどないんですよ
あの被害受けてる方々と皆様比較すると
もう大体同じです 大したことないんです
ご飯食べることにその方々ももう困ってる
皆さん困ってるしね もう大したことない
しかし 非現実的な苦であれば
被害を受けてない皆様方はその苦はないんです
精神的な苦はないんです
被害を受けた方々には
その巨大な精神苦も関わっているんです
私が言ったのは 精神的な苦は非現実性的で
これはなくせますよと
もうちょっと現実的に考えて妄想しないならば大丈夫だということです
残るのは体から起こるわずかな苦だけです
我々は理性で現実的な思考で妄想を極力やめて生きていると
苦しみがわずかしか残らないんです
このわずかな苦しみっていうのは
ちょっと喉が渇いた程度なんです
こんな大した苦しみじゃないでしょ
喉が渇いたらこれ水を飲めばいいでしょうに
なんかちょっと今日は食欲がないな
別に ご飯食べないでいればすぐ食欲が出てきますからね
そんな程度の苦しみしかなくなっちゃうんです
それは苦しみはあるんです
あ ちょっと疲れちゃ眠くなったとかね
横になれば だから現実苦っていうのはそんな程度なんです
しかし 妄想苦はとんでもない化け物なんです
しかし 人は妄想と思考の区別は知らない
それで私は妄想しないで思考しなさいと言ったでしょ
これわからないんです
何が妄想で何が思考かと教えてあげる気もないんで
今日は 特別な訓練をして
妄想の闇を破らなくてはいけないんです
だから あまりにも妄想しているんだから
妄想に馴染んでるんだから
特別思考訓練が必要なんです
妄想は人間にとって麻薬なので
なくす気にはなりませんね
この妄想っていうのは人間の麻薬なんです
心の麻薬なんです 妄想するとその世界でいられるでしょ
この服に火がついてますけど
まあ妄想でなんとあったかいですかねとかね
そういうわけだから 麻薬だから誰も妄想やめようという気を起こせないんです
それで私たちは妄想をやめる訓練させてますけど
みんなもう攻撃するんで
私に向かって そんなこと言ったっても
こういう思考は大事でしょうとかね
私はいきなり怒鳴るんです
別に怒ってない まあこいつはダメだとわかってるんだからね
はい じゃあ今適当に頑張ってください
言えばいいんだけど やっぱり指導者には責任がありますからね
結果出さないと だから私はものすごく怒鳴るんですけど
まあ聞いてくれませんよ
だから結構質問されますよ
妄想はダメだとわかってますけど
このように妄想すればいいんじゃないかっていう
これで論理的に私に勝てると思っているんです
はい これで苦二つありました
現実苦 非現実苦 我々は現実苦でいち苦しんでいるならば
百兆ぐらい妄想苦で苦しんでいるんです
あれってすべて余計なんです
すぐなくせるんです 現実苦は放っておくんです
お腹が空いたらご飯を食べるんです
これはあの題目唱えてもなくなりません
念仏唱えても意味がないんです
ヴィパッサナー 私が教えているヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっても
お腹が空いたらもうご飯食べるしかないんです
だから現実苦にはもう大したことないんです
はい 次のポイントに行きます
愛別離でしたっけ？はい
意味は好きな人と別れることだと思う
でしょうね 例えばね 家が
家が壊れること 家族が亡くなること
財産がなくなること 仕事がなくなること
これって愛別離苦でしょ？だって欲しいもん
自分が自分に欲しいでしょうね
その家が壊れちゃうと
これは悲しいんですよ
それが愛別離苦です と思ってますね
お釈迦様 そう心配じゃないんです
これが謎なんです まずそうだと思う
それでも OK です が 裏があるんです
これは一人一人が仏教を学んで
この裏の答えを発見しなくちゃいけないんですよ
これが悟りというんです
やるしょうもないんだからね
やる気も起こさないしね
だから一応答え出します
ます 生きること自体が愛別離苦で成り立っているのだ
我々は瞬間瞬間 その苦しみに侵されていると理解しましょう
これがですよ 答えが 愛別離苦は瞬間瞬間攻撃しているんです
この家が壊れたんだから愛別離苦じゃないんです
大地震と津波で愛別離苦になったと
そんなことはあり得ません
大地震が起こる前も愛別離苦でしたけどね
津波が起こる前にも愛別離苦なんです
生まれた瞬間から愛別する苦なんです
瞬間瞬間あるんです 分かりますかね
その意味は 離れると離れること多く
もう休憩した方がいいと思いますけど
このセクション終わってから
好きなもの 愛するもの
欲しいもの 必要なもの
楽しいものなどは自分で寄ってこないんですよ
でしょ？自分がそれを追っていって取らなくてはならないんです
金が欲しいでしょ？全然寄ってこないんです
はい 金が出てこないんです
自分で頑張って とっても使い
捕まえても自然に逃げるんですよ
これで欲しいものは取っても
この欲しいものはすーっと手から離れていくんです
金が なんで儲かろうと思ってます？結局使うためでしょ
ちょっとバイトして苦労して金が貯まったぞと言ったら
次の足で走るんですよ
買い物に もう買いたかったからカバン買いたかったんだとかね
もう走ってもう終わって逃げてるんです
時々逃げないようにじっと頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
皆様知らないですけど
男性たちはね 奥さんに嫌われないように
奥さんが逃げないようにとどれほど苦労しているのかと
初期だからその人と一緒になったんです
この人はその日から嫌がってますからね
旦那のこと もっといい王子
王子様と結婚できたのにとかね
だから男は結構苦労してますよ
死ぬまでこの戦いは続くんです
死ぬまで この夫婦のことでなくて
欲しいものは寄ってこないんです
だから追うんです これが苦しいんです
それで獲得しても逃げるんですね
これまた捕まえておかなくちゃいけないんです
これまた苦しいんです
これが瞬間瞬間もあるんです
朝から晩まで 我々はいつでも欲しいもののために動いてますよ
例えば 本を開けて読むということは楽しみが欲しいんです
これで苦労しながら読まなくちゃいかないんです
はい 読んだからという知識が頭に入りますか？で
入りません 入ってもすぐ消えちゃいます
すぐ忘れます これが空なんですよ
これが常にあるんです
ですから 当然津波でもう全部流されたことも苦しみですけど
愛別する苦ですけど こんな甘い話じゃないんです
そんなのはたまたま起こるものであって
百年 二百年一回もあんな大地震が起きません
これはこの島で言ったってもね
また二百年待ってくださいということでしょうね
だから二百年ぐらい楽しく安心して生きていればいいでしょうに
淡路島ね もうすごい地震で大変損を受けたでしょ
またそうとも百年 百五十年また地震起きませんからね
その間に安心していればいいでしょうに
だからそんなのは愛別する苦にするんじゃないんです
そんなのは放っておけばいいっていうことです
家が流されちゃった あ
わかった じゃあ避難所に行くぞと
それで問題は解決です
で そういう気楽な思考ができないんです
妄想のおかげで だから避難所ででも歌ったり踊ったり
もう大騒ぎして あの神社のお祭りみたいな気分でいればいいでしょう
なんでこうやっているんですかね
避難所でもう本当に不自由ですよ
不自由だけど これはもう全然気にしないで
みんなで一緒にじゃあ歌いましょう
じゃあ踊りましょうとかね
あれやこれやとかね 新しい踊りを学んでもらったり
ヨガでもやってみたり
まあむちゃくちゃなことをやれば
ものすごく楽しいと思いますよ
あっちこっちもうね あの壊れたとこもありますから
そういうところでも行ってね
いろいろものを拾ってきて
避難所のところにいろいろお飾りをつけてあげたりとか
いろんなやり方があります
だから何がなくなったっていうことは
そんなに落ち込む必要はないんです
しかし 愛別する苦はそんな甘いものじゃなくて
我々は瞬間的に攻撃しているんです
で 今も私ずっと立ってるんですけど
まあ入った時はちょっと体力があって元気でしたけど
もう体力が逃げているんですよ
だからまた追っかけて
おいでおいでとかね また体力つけなくちゃいけなくなるんです
これが愛別する苦なんです
この戦いは生きることなんです
で 欲しいと必要と思われるものをすべて
ご飯は勝手に体に入らない
美人はナンパしない限りはね
金や財産は苦労しない限りは手に入らない
健康もスマートな体も
また知識も苦労しない限りは手に入らない
健康でいたいと思ってね
ソファに座ってせんべい食べたら
健康でいたければ もう毎日時間走れということになるんです
ですから 欲しいものは苦労しなきゃ手に入らないんです
入ってもこいつら逃げるんですよ
だから離れること 追う苦が愛別する苦というんです
しかし すべて自分から逃げるんです
欲しいものの決まりは逃げることです
これ すごい難しい哲学なんです
私に対して欲しいもの
必要なものはすべて逃げるものなんです
寄ってくるものじゃないんです
だから欲しいものがあると
その分苦しみが生まれるんです
必要なものってどうしようもないでしょ
その分苦しみがあるんです
例えば 私にもご飯が必要です
その分が苦しみです 時々私は待っていますけど
全然ご飯が勝手に出てこないんですよ
やっぱり自分で追っていかないと
生きる努力とは 自分に寄ってこない好きなものを追うこと
でしょ？生きるっていうのは
得てもそれらは自然に離れていくから
逃がさないように苦労することも生きることです
という限りのない ２つの努力です
生きるとは限りない 2つの努力
欲しいものを追うことと
得たものは逃げないようにすること
それでも自分の妄想 希望
願望通りにはいかないもので
不満で恐怖感で落ち着くが
落ち着けないでいることになります
はい 愛別する苦はなんとかすることはできますけど
苦ですけど どうしようもないんです
これに希望 願望入ってるでしょ
希望 願望入っちゃうと
欲しいものは欲しいほど入らなかったんです
これで精神的に不安になっちゃうんです
例えば入ったんだけど
なくなったらどうしようかと
家に泥棒入ったらどうしようかと
例えば健康にいる方々はあえてすごい不安なんです
突然病気になったらどうしようかと
私には一度健康じゃないんだから
体はね がんになったらどうしようかとか思ったことないんです
突然心臓発作起こったら
死んだらどうしようかとかね
もともと体悪いんだからね
しかし 健康な方々にはその不安があるんです
だから妄想が絡んできて
また恐怖感 不安などなどを作るんです
これが愛別する苦の話です
はい これで次に行きますので
ちょっと休憩いたします
はい 次 怨憎会苦ですね
これもたまに起こる苦ではありません
普通はまあたまたまっていう風になっちゃいますね
この苦からも解放されることもできません
ことはできません で 怨憎会苦っていうのは
一般的な説明で言えば
嫌な人と付き合わなくちゃいけないとかね
でね 会社でね 気に入らない人がいるんですけど
毎日会社に会社に行かなくちゃいけないし
そういうふうなことは苦しみだと
旦那さんのことをものすごく嫌になっているんですけど
まあ離婚するわけにいきませんだからね
もうずっともう頑張らなくちゃいけないとかね
そういうふうに思っちゃうと
まあこれがまあ苦しみですけど
まあそんなものかと そういうものではなくてね
前に説明しましたから
これもこの深いところを調べてみると
結構大変なものなんです
瞬間瞬間 怨憎会苦を経験しているんです
私たちはたまたま嫌な人と出会ったわけじゃなくて
瞬間瞬間 怨憎会苦で苦しんでいるんです
人はいくら嫌がっても
それに構わず 病弱になっていく
老いていく 死を向かって生きるんです
で まずお釈迦様が説明しているのは
そのこのこのヒントなんですよ
怨憎会苦に理解するための
で 私は毎日毎日何をやっているのかというと
衰えているんです 毎日
毎日 毎秒 毎秒 ドカンドカンドカンと死を向かって走っているんです
止まれません だから老いること
嫌でしょ それから体の健康っていうのは毎日壊れるものであって
健康が上がるものじゃないんです
毎日体力が減るものであって
増えるものじゃないんです
でも嫌でしょ そんなのは
正直なところ嫌です 体力が減るのは嫌です
老いるのも嫌です 死を向かって走るのは嫌です
できれば死から走りたいでしょ
死神が皆様出かける時でもね
今日は死神は北だったら南の方に向かって出かけるんだからね
鬼門と言うんですか？だから鬼門と言ったっても
あれはインド文化のインド文化というか
インドの迷信のパクリですからね
インドでは死神 死神と言うんです
だから毎日出るんです
今日は死神は 死神は北
今日は東北とかね 今日は南とかね
これ見て あ 南だったら今日は北を見て
もう出かけなくちゃいかんとかね
とにかく死神に背を見せるんです
これは人間のアホな世界で
現実な世界は死神を見て
そちらにまっしぐらに生きているんです
私は 私たちは東西南北どこを見て歩いたっても
死神 死神を目かけて歩いているんですが
死にとは死にたくはないんです
嫌です そういうことで
生老病死は嫌なんですけど
生老病死を迎って生きているんですね
それって温相会なんです
嫌なことには確実に出会わなくちゃいけないんです
微塵も逃げることできないんです
年取ることは  １秒の 100分の1でもストップはできません
ですから そこは嫌なことと会うことなんです
だから 我々にとっては常に音相会苦があるんです
寄ってくること 避ける苦
その場合は寄ってくる苦
避ける苦という 逃げる苦と追う苦があったんですね
寄ってくる苦と避ける苦があるんです
追い出しても追い出しても
蚊が勝手に寄ってくるんでしょ
これでわかりますよ 人生は
例えば昆虫好きな人がね
例えば珍しい蝶々がいるんだそうと言ったら
この珍しい蝶々がパタパタパタパタ飛んできて
自分の指の上で止まってくれればね
なんで幸せですかね 観察することも
写真撮ることも何でもできますよ
寄ってこないんです これで蝶々を探しに藪に入ったら
蚊は寄ってくるんです
だから それだけでも人生は見えるでしょう
だから 道元さんが言ったように
常に仏法を語られているんだと
どこを見ても 滝の声はそれが仏法そのものであると
滝の音は 仏法は滝の音のようなものではないんだよと
滝の音が仏法であると
本当のことを言ってるんです
うん 私も一応同じことを言っているんです
藪に入ったら蚊が寄ってくる
蝶々は逃げる だから蝶々は欲しいものですね
だから なんとかネットを持って追っかけていかなくちゃいけないんです
蚊が寄ってくるんだから
いかに追い出すのかと
また苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
病 不幸 災難 災害 経済不振
人生の不安 ライバルの攻撃などの嫌なこと
すべて勝手に寄ってくるんです
誰にも地震起こさせることはできませんよ
起こすことは 津波をいくら頑張っても作ることはできません
原子爆弾でも海の中で爆発する程度ですね
津波は起こせません そんなのは勝手に起こるんです
嫌なことっていうのは
ライバルたちはこそこそと勝手に計画を立てて
自分を倒すんです 自分たちが家を作っても
セキュリティをつけても
泥棒たちはずっと計画を立てて
勝手にいかに攻撃しようかなとか実行するんです
生きていきたい人は 絶えずそれらを追い出さなくてはならないんです
生きていきたければ まあザザーと寄ってくるこの嫌なものを全部取っ払わなくちゃ
追い出さないと生きていられませんよ
ライバルがいて 自分に何か罠を仕掛けているならば
自分もそこにはめられないようにいろいろ工夫しなくちゃいけない
蚊が寄ってくると まあ体の中に何か虫除けのあれを塗ったり
蚊取り線香を立てたり
いろいろやらなくちゃいけない
どちらでも苦なんです
両方も苦です  わかりやすいですね
しかし 今日 あの 私は知恵が開発してほしいんです
人間は人をマスコミで言うことを信じるんじゃなくて
理性で考える能力があってほしいんです
だから私はそれを今育てようとしているんです
脳を動かしてやろうと
ですから この言葉を覚えてください
何でしたっけ？寄ってくること
離れる 避ける これ ずっとあるんです
これが人生なんです だから生きる努力っていうのは
何もしないでいても 無数の嫌なもの
命を脅かすものが絶えず寄ってくるんです
例えば 何もしないで生まれてきた赤ちゃんがどこかに置いておけばどうなるんですかね？死にます
若者たちはね 勉強は嫌いで
遊んでいるでしょう とんでもないこと寄ってくるんですよ
何も能力がなくなったとかね
そういうわけで いろいろ悪いことばっかりやってくるんです
何もしないことで この鈍足に陥るんです
そこで戦わないと 我々はこの鈍足に陥るんです
泥棒が入っても何もしないんだったら
もうどうしようもないですよ
次から次へ泥棒が入ると入るんだから
病気が勝手にかかるでしょ
誰もお願いして病気にかかったことないでしょ
小学生ぐらいですね 学校に行きたくなく
行きたくない気分になったら
何かお腹でも壊れないかとかね
熱でも出てこないのかとかね
もう考えるのはね まあ小学生の子供ぐらいですけどね
スリランカの子供たちは
そこを出す方法まで知ってるんです
あの 皆さんは小学生はいないんですね
じゃあ教えてあげます
あの 何だったっけな ニンニクありますね
ニンニクを半分半分切って身に刺しておくんです
大体 5 分経ってくると
もうすごい熱なんです
測ってみたらもう高熱です
で それで大体そこで熱を出してから
お母ちゃん 今日は熱ですから
まあやっぱり あるいは学校ででもそれやってね
先生 あ やっぱりあなた熱出たから帰ってください
それから何のことない
また 10 分で元に戻るんで
そのケース以外はね 喜んで病気になるっていうことはあり得ないんです
病気が勝手に寄ってくる
我々は追い出すこと 戦うでしょ
両方苦しいでしょ 薬飲んだり治療したりするのはもう嫌なことでしょうに
病気も嫌なことなんです
勉強したり 仕事をしたり
能力を上げたり 身を守ったりして戦わなくてはいけないんです
だから我々は戦っているんです
勉強します 仕事もします
能力も上げ向上しようとする
年取ってもいろいろ学んだりする
ずっと戦っているんです
何に対して戦っているかというと
怨争 怨争と戦っているんです
しかし これも大変な苦しみです
楽じゃないんですよ 勉強も仕事も
これが生きる努力というものです
はい 次は苦に立ちはだかってもというテーマで
皆やってるから みんなやってますよ
これが やってるが 苦に立ち向かうことは愚かな行為です
これもうかなわないんです
苦は だって今 音そう苦で説明したでしょうに
何もしないと嫌なこと寄ってくるんだから苦しいんですね
これ戦うでしょ これも苦しいんです
病気になることも 治療することも両方苦しいんですよ
そういうことで戦っちゃうと
いわゆる立ちはだかろうと思っちゃうと
さらに苦しみが勝つんです
むちゃくちゃ戦ってやるぞと思っちゃうと
もう負けます 徹底的に健康でいようかなと思って
徹底的に管理しちゃうと
早く病気になって死にます
勝てくはないんです もうスポーツして筋肉ビチビチ
力があってね 早く死にますよ
苦とは徹底研究して理解するものです
苦しみっていうのを今日覚えておいてください
苦しみっていうのは もうこの野郎
潰してやるぞではなくて
放っておく これは生きることだからね
しかし 今日みたいに徹底的に苦とは何かと勉強するんです
して理解するんです あ
なるほど こういうものができることはと
これで十分です それが人生を学ぶことでもあります
正しく人生を学ぶということは
苦を学ぶことなんです
生きることは苦であると知る人は落ち着くんです
お釈迦様は生きることは苦であると知った人が解脱に達しますよと
だから説かれてます はい
これで終わり 苦は別なテーマに雑談的に入ります
この自然と生命の関係
もうとんでもない別なテーマです
自然は命を育む 何でしたっけ？育むのでしょうかと
と思っていますね 自然っていうのは無関心です
命に対して 条件が揃ったからこの世で命が現れただけなんです
あの この生命の起源とかね
まあいろいろ一般的な知識いっぱいあるでしょ
世の中で で あまり明確に誰もわかりませんだけど
こうなったんじゃないか
こうなったんじゃないかとかね
科学者はいろいろ推測はしています
そこで その推測から見れば
まあ地球ではいろいろあって
厳しい状態が があって
これはどんどん変わって
なんとなく生命誕生に条件が揃ってしまったんですね
それで生命が現れたんだけど
まだ解決してないんです
どうやって現れたかっていうことをいまだにわかってないんです
自然に現れたか あるいはどこかの生命が入っていた
微生物とか何か入っていた
何かあの 何て言いますか
空から降ってくるものには
隕石 まあ隕石ですね 何か隕石はドカンと海に落ちたかとかね
まあそれぞれいろいろは考えはあります
一番流行の神が作ったということです
地球環境 環境によって生きている生命の体の形
生き方なども変わるんですよ
だから恐竜もいたでしょうに
それから酸素を呼吸しない生命も昔いたんですよ
地球大気圏に酸素がなかった時
生命がいたんです 酸素は呼吸しないんです
それであの海の中に火山がありますね
一応酸素がないんです
火山ガスばっかりなんです
生命がいるんですよ だから酸素は取らないんです
そこでものすごい暑いでしょ
大丈夫です ですから この自然環境に合わせて
生命の体も形も生き方も変わっていくんです
これからも地球環境変化によって生命の生き方も変わっていくんですよ
そこでたまたま今人間がいるでしょ
たまたま人間が現れたんです
地球環境が変わったんだから
そこでこの環境変化すると
私たちはもうさようならです
でも簡単に 人間が特別でも王者でもありません
これよく言ってますからね
西洋の哲学者たちが 人間がもう全部支配して王でいるんだと
何言うのか 微生物に負けてるのに
こういうヘリクスはもう本当に嫌なんですよ
だから私はもうコンピューターでゲームはやるんだけど
情報は調べません もうヘリクスだらけで
で 微生物にも負けてね
最近ね あのインフルエンザウイルスの大げさになっていたでしょうに
豚インフルエンザもあったり
鳥インフルエンザもあったり
もうみんな怯えちゃってね
こんなもんだから 王者って誰ですかね
で それから自然っていうのは優しくないんです
自然は生命を育もうと思ってないんです
たまたま生まれただけなんです
自然のままで生きていても幸福になるとは言えません
自然のままで生きていたっても
幸福になるとはわかりませんよ
生きるものは多かれ少なかれ自然を破壊しているんです
微生物から人間まで我々は自然を破壊しているんです
これで生きているんです
だから自然に従って 自然のままで生きるということはあり得ないんです
今日でもこういうポイントを勉強してください
世間で言っていることと
我々仏教側が言うことはね
結構違います この破壊は命を育む育んだ環境を壊すことでもあります
そこで我々は生きるために環境を破壊しなくちゃいけないんですよ
環境破壊すると作ると
命を作った環境が壊れているんです
じゃあ環境破壊しなかったら死ぬんです
だから微生物も環境を破壊する
我々も環境を破壊している
鳥たちも環境を破壊している
他の生き物も環境を破壊している
あのイースト菌はとてもひどいでしょうに
糖分が入っている液体に入れちゃうと
まあ元気に生きてますね
どんどん増えますね 破壊するんで
環境が 環境破壊してみんな死んじゃいます
それで酒ができあがっちゃいますね
だからイースト菌が自分の体から出すんでしょ
もうあの 中の酸素を取ってるんだから
いろいろ化学物質を出しちゃって
これが毒で死んじゃいます
で 私たちはイースト菌ではないんだけど
私たちももっと大きいスケールで環境を破壊して生きているんです
これでなんとなくおかしくない？また矛盾が見えてこない
徐々に生きづらくなるのは当然です
だから どんな生命にも徐々に生きづらくなるんです
この決まったもんです
それが 日本は世界でももしかするときれいな水のある国の中で第１やと思いますけどね
今どうですかね 私も水を買って飲んでるんです
それで自然っていうのは
ですから 優しくはないんです
我々にとっては無関心です
自然は我々破壊したんだからといって
自然にとっては痛くも痒くもないんです
あのアメリカで誰かが言ったんですから
人間がこの地球から消えちゃうと
100年で残るのは あのアメリカのどこの山の上で何か誰かさんの顔を彫ってるでしょ
それと万里の長城とピラミッドだけやと
すべて 100年で消えますよ
たった 100年 で こんなもんで
だから我々の破壊っていうのはね
自然界にとってはね あなたは何がやったの？という
いう状態なんです そこで私たちは自然破壊をやっている途中で
自然を甘く見るというとんでもない失敗するんです
知識や不完全な科学のせいで
私はあえて不完全な科学と書くんですけどね
もう誰の悪口も言ってますからね
不完全な科学のせいで
人間は自然を手に取って遊べるも
これはものの感じが間違っています
遊べるものだと思っているのです
自然っていうのは もうちょろいちょろい手に取って遊べるものやとかと思ってるんです
人間だけです じゃあ甘く見てはいけませんよ
人間が復活不可能なところまで自然破壊をするんです
はい そこで復活不可能っていうことは
このちょっと意味が違います
人間に生命に生きられる状態
そこは復活不可能なところまで破壊するんです
こんな科学者たちにはね
そんな自然破壊なんかできるわけじゃないんです
が 調子に乗り上がってやってる破壊によって
我々に生きていられなくなってるだけ
人間だけがあまりにも生きることに執着しているんですから
それが起こるんです そこで新しい問題が出てくるんです
動物たちは餌があったら食べる
餌がなかったらそのままいる
で 死んでしまいます とにかく生きていようとはしないんです
人間がそうじゃなくて
とにかく生きてみるぞという
あまりの執着があるんだから
その分は自然破壊はするんです
原発はとてもいい例なんです
やりたい放題 エネルギーを使いまくってやるぞと
そこまでエネルギーが必要ですかね
たまたま停電があったってのは死にませんでしょう
これで東京って言って巨大な土地でしょ
全部もう昼のように明るくしなくちゃいけないんですね
ビルやら看板があるわあるわ
なんでこれやと だって針 1本落ちても拾えますからね
夜は そこまでいるんですかね
そこまで威張るんですかね
そこまで調子に乗っちゃって
自然破壊しなくちゃいけないんです
だから畑作ることも自然破壊ですけど
大したことはないんですよ
一年は作らなかったら元に戻っちゃいますね
まあ原発も大したことはないんで
まあたとえあとこれからね
まあ大体 2万年  1万年
2万年ぐらいになると
もう元に戻ると思います
人間だけが他の生命の生きる権利を無視するんです
ですから 人間だけが他の生命の生きる権利を無視して破壊するんです
他の生命はそうしません
これは生きることに対する執着なんです
生きることは空だとわかったらね
こんな執着するもんじゃないよと
とわかるでしょうに はい
それから自然界の自然
私は自然の自然とまず書いて
これで何か悪口言われるでしょ
あんたの日本語間違っているということで
自然界の自然とまた訂正したんです
地震 津波 火山爆発 竜巻
台風 洪水 干ばつなどは自然そのものなんです
全然不思議じゃないんです
自然界に寄生している生き物には関係ない出来事です
この言葉を覚えてください
我々は自然界に寄生しているんです
自然界が我々を育んでいるわけじゃないんです
たまたま命を誕生しちゃったんです
これが自然界に寄生しているんです
だから寄生虫っていうのは壊すでしょ
舞台を だから我々は当然壊さなくちゃいけないんです
システムを生きるために
だから寄生生命には関係ないんです
竜巻 津波とかは これは普通
人間がいてもいなくても起こるんです
自然界の自然は 生き物にとっては何の太刀打ちもできないとんでもない迷惑なんです
だから環境が変わるんだからね
生きていられないんです
火山爆発すると そこら辺はもう生きていられない
もう環境が変わったんです
だから火山爆発してから何十年か経つと
特別な植物だけも命が始まるんです
それは我々の食べるものでも何でもなくて
その厳しい環境でも生きていられる
植物 苔とかね まあ初めて
それからどんどんどんどん環境が変わって
我々にも生きられるようになってくるんです
結構時間かかります ですから
この地震 津波などについて
そのように見なくちゃいけないんですね
これは自然界の自然であって
寄生生命には関係ないことであると
しかし 我々にとってはとんでもない迷惑である
文句を言う権利がないんです
あんた方は寄生でしょうにと
地球に地球を恨んでも意味がないんです
自然が生かしてくれるが
命は極限に危ういものです
だから自然は無関心だから
まあ破壊したっても まあまあ無関心です
破壊に対してで攻撃はしないんです
アメリカはむちゃくちゃ原子爆弾実験やったでしょ？むちゃくちゃ自然破壊したんですけど
まあ地球は別にまあ気にしないんです
いわゆる放ってくれているんです
我々を から放っておくことが生かしてくれると言葉で言うだけ
だから だからといって
自然はどうぞお元気で幸せに生きてくださいとはないんです
ですから このよく人間いうことで
これ神の祟りかと まあたくさんありますけど
まあそれだけにしたんです
災害とは神の祟りでも悪魔の仕業でもありません
そんなのは 災害という単語も人間の都合の言葉で
自然が悪をやっているわけではありません
この災害という単語さえもおかしいんです
これ 人間勝手に作った単語であって
災害ではなくて自然現象なんです
神がすべてを支配しているのだと矛盾を言う人々は
自然という背景の中で
命は鳥にも足らない惨めなものだと分かっていないんです
森羅万象を創造して支配しているんだという人々は
人間様が偉いと思っているんです
人間に特別に霊魂を与えて
特別な存在だとか そこまで嘘言うのかいと
ちょっと見たら違うでしょうに
人間 生命っていうのは惨めなんですよ
微生物から人間まで寄生して生きているだけなんです
ちょっとの地震で死にます
ちょっとの津波でもう消えます
台風が来たらもう亡くなっているんです
洪水でも人が死んでるんです
日本でも人が自然ではなくて事故で死ぬということは毎日でしょう
だから我々の命というのはものすごく惨めなんです
だから目を覚ましてみてほしいんです
神が創ったと言った時点でとんでもないことでしょうに
とんでもない神になっちゃうでしょうに
このシステムだから そこまで妄想して勘違いしたらダメです
生きる道が外れてはダメなんです
生きる道があるんです
この苦を理解して生きることに執着しないことなんです
神とは自然であるならば
災害は祟りではありません
逆に日本の方々は神という言葉を使いますけど
どちらかというと自然に神と言っているんですね
神道では太陽に神と言っているんですね
ある宮司さんが私に説明してくれたんですよ
神だよと 神っていうのは太陽で
身っていうのは地球のことであると
そう 全て生命がその中でおかげで生きているんだから
仏教よりは偉いんだと
神道はと ブッダも神の下で生活しなくちゃいけなかったでしょうにと
まあそれはその通りですねと言って
もうどうせもうね 話し相手にならないんですからね
また攻撃するところじゃなくて
すごくありがたく来てくださいと言って
ごちそうしてくれて いろいろ案内してくれたんだから
まあちょっと礼儀ってものがありますからね
はい 日本ではまあもうそういう地球と太陽とかね
自然は神だと思っている場合もあります
それだったら別にまあそんなに間違いはないんです
それだったら祟りだと言うなよと
地震 津波などは これは自然の自然法則なんです
それから人災っていうものはあるんですね
家を作ること 井戸を掘ることさえも自然破壊です
しかし 人間は度を超えて破壊に挑戦するんです
家を作ることはまあ度を越えてないんです
井戸を掘ったっても度を越えてないんです
使わなくなったらそれ消えますからね
自然に だから度を超えてないんです
我々は度を超えて自然破壊しているんです
自然災害をはるかに超えた人災に遭遇しなくてはいけなくなっているんです
だから 津波で地震で死ぬ人々よりも
戦争で死ぬ人々 化学兵器で死ぬ人々
大量破壊兵器で死ぬ人々
新しく作ったウイルスで死ぬ人々
このエイズウイルスやらね
いろいろ きりがないんです
人災で死んだ人々の数はもう比較にならないほど多いんです
干ばつで死んだ人 飢えた人少ないんです
あのギリシャ イタリアでもね
昔 ヴィスウエスという火山がありましてね
それで街全部ローマがなくなったでしょ
しかし その人々は互い殺し合って
どれぐらい人を殺したとします
この町一つ全体的に亡くなったんだけど
そんなたくさんの人々じゃないんです
その人々は戦争をして
ものすごいたくさんの人を殺しちゃったんです
だから人災の方が甚だしく危険性が多いんです
うかつな自然破壊は復活復興できないのです
ですから うかつに自然破壊しても
もう復興はできません
犯人は誰ですか？と 生きることにある強烈な執着は犯人です
人を殺してでも生きてやるぞと
戦争してでも生きてやるぞという
何よ これ 隣の国の人々を殺して
財産を奪って 自分の領土を広げて自慢してやるぞと
そんなに自慢すること大事ですかね
最近でいえばね イギリス帝国がね
一番大きかったでしょう
今何？あのイギリスは
自分でも生きていられない状態でしょう
いまだに戦争をするんで
アメリカが戦争しようかなと思ったら
イギリスがやります やります
イギリスの応援でなければ
アメリカももうちょっと考えますよ
あの連中は人を殺さなきゃ気が済まないという
だからそれっていうのは
生きることに対するこの度を超えた強烈な執着が
イギリス人が悪いじゃないんです
ヒットラーとかその連中が悪いんじゃないんです
このみんなの心の中で生きることにある
この頭がイカれている
この執着 例えばヒットラーが頭イカレていたでしょうに
この生きる執着に だから犯人がこの
この執着なんですよ これ治療しなくちゃいけないんです
欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどの感情は共犯です
生きることは苦だと気づかないので犯罪者になってしまうんです
だから我々人類 みんな犯罪者なんです
人類みんなに執着があるんです
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみがあるんです
だから犯人は誰ですか？と言いたっても
もう生きることに執着する人はみんな犯人なんです
だから原発を一部の人々が作ったんだけど
我々にも欲があったんだからね
日本は開発して ああ 良かったな
どうだい 我々はと威張ってたでしょ
私も原発の電気使っていたでしょうに
私も自分の国では停電は度々ですけど
こちらでは停電は一回も経験したことがないんだそうとかね
このつけが来るんです
だから共犯なんです 原発事故の場合は
日本国民みんな共犯なんです
残念ですけど 嫌だと思ったらね
できんでしょうに 我々は小欲知足で生きていますよと威張らなくてもいいやん
いいやと 元気で健康で
死ぬまで平和で生きていられれば十分じゃないと言ったらならば
西洋を追い起こさなくてもいいんじゃない？と言ったならば
これないでしょ 特別手を加えなくても
皆発展という代物に賛成しているので
失敗すると人類が道連れになります
ですから今はグローバルでしたっけ？になって
今TPPやらFTPPやらあれやこれやとかね
もうもう道連れにして死のうと思っているんです
はい そのポイントは自然との関係がね
生きることはたとえ辛くてもなぜ悩むのでしょうかと
生きることは辛いものです
だからって悩む必要はあるのかっていうこと
愛着の問題 家 1軒が壊れたと聞いても無関心です
驚きもしない それはあなたの家ですよと言われたら
その瞬間で失神して倒れます
それからも立ち直ることはできなくなります
あのね あの家 1軒壊れましたよ
そういう面白くないこと持っていくなよ
言うなよとうるさいやと言うんです
あのね あれはあなたの家ですよと
そこで問題です 人はたくさん死んでも無関心ですが
家族の一人が亡くなると耐えられない悲しみに陥るんです
例えばね リビアでもたくさんの人が死んじゃったでしょうに
全然気にもしないね しかし
自分の家族の一人が亡くなると
これは耐えられなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 愛着ですね 問題は
人の死を悲しむのは優しい人だからと世間が思っているんです
人の死は悲しむべきものやって
優しい人やと これは世間の考えで
一切の生命の死を悲しむならば
哀れむならば それが真の優しさですが
やってますかね 日本の方々はね
世界の人間が苦しむ時は悲しみますけど
世界人口の 4分の1ぐらい魚釣っているんです
取って食べなくて捨てるんですよ
それは悲しくなんとも
もうカツオ取れなくなったと泣くなくなって泣いてるんです
ああ 悲しいやとかね それで私たちも
ああ なんとかしてカツオを取れるように
世間話でしたっけ しなくちゃいけないんだ
これは大変だと思ったりもして
なんだこれだと思いますけどね
親しい人々の不幸や死が悲しいし
耐えられない 他人の不幸や死に対しては冷静でいられる
そこは私はこの非難の言葉で言ってるんじゃなくて
こちらにポイントがあるんです
この愛着だよと 愛着さえなければ
執着さえなければ 常に生きることはつらいなのに冷静でいられます
自分の子供であっても死にますから
自分の親であっても死にますから
問題は冷静でいられなくなっちゃうんですね
それは愛着が絡んでくるんだからなんです
知りたくないが 知るべきことがあるんです
これ ちょっと厳しいんです
祖母 祖父 両親 伴侶 兄弟
子供 友人 これらの死は悲しいんです
何もしてあげることはできなかったという気持ち
で自分を責めると同時に
自分が損したこと 寂しいという気持ちですね
もあります 本当は腹黒いんですよ
親が亡くなった もう悲しくて
もうどうしようもなくなったと言っても
どうしようもないとね
言っても言っても 優しい人
親のことをよく思っている人だと
今更 生きてる時 あんたどうやったのかと聞きたくなるんです
本当に私に相談に来た方々
人が二人ぐらいいてね
親が死んでもう悲しくてたまらんよと
それは怒鳴ったんです
あんた 自分のことしか考えてないだろうと
生きてる時 面倒見たのかと
看病したのかと だから悲しいんだと
今更忘れようと 親が生きている時はもうとんでもない無関心でいて
ということなんですね
とにかく私たちにとっては
特に子供が亡くなると
もう寂しくてたまらんです
親が亡くなるともう寂しくてたまらんです
特に子供が小さい時 独立していないと
親が亡くなると 子供にとってはもう耐えがたいショックになるんです
大人はそれほどないんだけど
まあお年ですから まあしょうがないと思う場合ありますけど
子供の場合はもう泣き崩れるんです
理由はわがままです お母さん亡くなったら私はどうしますか？ということなんです
お母さんほど誰も私のことを心配してくれないんだよと
この悲しみはすーっとついてくるんです
当然ですけど お母さんほどは人は優しくないかもしれませんよ
だからってお母さんのために悲しくなるなることが優しさではなくて
自我なんです 自分が損したっていう気分なんです
だから お釈迦様が仏弟子たちに厳しく戒めてますよ
死を悲しまないこと それは情けないんだと
エゴイストをなくさなくちゃいけないんです
エゴイストの気分がなくなると
もっと面倒見てあげた方がよかったなという程度は出てきますよ
エゴイストでない場合は面倒見るんだからね
親がもう病気でもう大変だと言っても
私は忙しいやと言ってエゴイストでしょうに
だからお釈迦様は正しいことは言ってるんです
エゴイストであること
自分のことばっかし考えることをやめなさいよ
慈しみで生きてみなさいよ
そうなってくると ちゃんと親孝行するんです
そうすると 親が老いて亡くなる時でも
楽しく いい子供が 私の子供はいい子供やと
子供にもありがとうという一言を言って亡くなるんです
これでもうすっと気持ちがよくなっちゃいますよ
ギャーギャー泣くことじゃなくて
私よかったと お母さんがとても楽しい気分で亡くなったと
だからそこは欲しいんですよ
泣き崩れることじゃなくて
だから厳しい言葉ですけど
自分の親しい人の死を悲しむっていうことはエゴイストなんです
悲しみは自我愛によるものです
だから仏教は自我愛はなくすことを推薦しているんです
解決できるでしょうか
それでこの最後のセクションです
じゃあこの生きることつらいということは解決できますかと
アドバイスですから 読むだけで十分だと思います
苦がなくては生きることそのものも成り立たない
で理解する 苦は生きることです
逃げることできません
どのように手を打っても苦がなくならない
だから苦しみをなくすような手を打つものじゃないんです
生きるとは 愛別する苦と怨憎い苦の限りのない戦いです
この 4 種類の苦が出てくるんです
この 2つで 我々は限りない戦いをしなくちゃいけないんだ
生きるためには このルールに違反したい気持ちはあっても
それが不可能です 時々我々はルールを守らないで戦う時もあります
しかし これは不可能です
愛別する苦はルールです
怨憎い苦はルールです
ルールに従って生きてみなくちゃいけないんです
すべては無常なのです
幸も不幸も無常です 自分の都合に
妄想に 欲望に 願望によって変わるものではありません
だから幸福はずっとあってほしいでしょ
ありえません 無常だから
敵の不幸だったらすっとあってほしいでしょ
不幸もそのうち消えます
しかし 我々は不幸になったら早くもなくしてほしいと思っちゃうでしょ
これもありえません これはわがままです
もう起きた出来事はそれなりの時間が必要です
死んでほしくないと思うから
死は悲しくなるんです
死んでほしくないと我々思っちゃいますよ
これってもうとんでもない希望なんです
これが悲しみを作るんです
しかし 死は自然です 太刀打ちできません
愛情を打ち切って理性を育てるんです
ですから 愛情 感情ですね
愛情じゃなくて感情を打ち切って
貪瞋痴は感情です 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみというのは感情です
そんなのはもういいや
もう理性で生きてみますよということで
解決します 次に私のものっていうことは問題なんですよ
だから家が壊れました
だから何とどうしようでしょ
あなたの家ですよと言った途端
悲しみに陥りますからね
だから私のということが問題なんです
人が死んでも そんなのは当たり前と言うんですよ
あなたの誰か死んだと言ったら
もう大変です だから この私のというこの言葉が我々に苦しみを作るんです
私がいるとは成り立ちません
たくさん細胞がもう生老病死をやっているだけで私がいません
私の体の中でどんな細胞が私ですかね
細胞一個一個見たら私じゃなくて
別々な仕事をしているんですからね
あなたとは関係ないんだと言ってるんです
それで私は誰ですかね
成り立ってないんです
まして 私のものがあると思うことは
極まりのない無知の証拠です
私も成り立たないんだから
私のものをと思ったら
これは極まりのない無知です
だから 私にとっては この私の私の私のということはよく考えてコントロールした
制御した方がいいと思います
私のものなら なぜ私の自在にならないのでしょうか
例えば私の犬といっても
犬は犬の勝手に生きているでしょう
私の犬なんですけど 私は犬に合わせなくちゃいけないんですね
これおかしいでしょ 私の犬なのに
犬にも あなたもね あの
何て言いますか お箸で食べなさいとかっこいいやとやりませんね
口で食べるんですね ですから
私たちはやっぱり私の犬なのに
犬に合わせる合わせるしかないんです
私の子供なのに 子供の性格に合わせてこちらが奴隷にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから私のものと言っても
結局あなた奴隷になっているでしょう
私の家と言ったら家の奴隷になっているんです
私のお金と言ったら それ金の奴隷になっているんです
だから 私のということは
あなたは奴隷であるという意味なんです
あなたは自在ではありませんと
自由がありませんという意味なんです
これは何とかしなくちゃ
私のものはないと思わない限りは
なくなるものは 離れるものは
壊れるものは 私のものではありません
全部もう自然法則によってなくなる
壊れる 離れていく だから私のということは成り立たないんです
太陽を見ようと 太陽は私のものではありませんね
私に管理することはできません
私の希望通りにはなりませんね
それぐらいわかるでしょうね
しかし 私は太陽の力を借りてなんとか生きているだけです
太陽がないと生きられていられませんね
エネルギーというものはすべて太陽のものだからね
あの水力発電といったっても
あれは太陽のエネルギーなんです
原発は違いますけど それ以外
すべてのエネルギーは太陽のエネルギーなんです
キャベツを食べても元気になるでしょ
あれ 太陽のエネルギーなんです
ですからだからで太陽は私の言うことはやにもやりません
で これで生き方わかりますよ
太陽は私のものではないんだけど
お世話にはなっています
太陽に感謝します 太陽は馬鹿野郎とは何の意味もない言葉なんです
だからもう太陽は拝んだんだからといって
日本が太陽を拝むでしょ
日本に特別に太陽が何かやってくれるかというと
そうでもありません 太陽を拝むことは絶対しない
自分の国にも太陽がちゃんと現れます
これが自然の中で生きる時の決まりです
だから 太陽を見れば どのように生きるべきかわかります
これだけで十分ですね
もう余計なことをたくさん書きましたけど
執着を控えて気楽になる
何かに執着しても それが自分から必ず離れる
また自分が離れなくてはならないこともあります
その執着するものが離れるか
自分が離れてしまうか
どちらか どちらでも苦しいんです
執着は無知な人 感情の奴隷になって理性が失った人の特色です
執着っていうのは無知な人の特色で
感情にやられている人々の特色です
執着は成り立ちません
本当は執着は成り立ちません
太陽を執着したら成り立たないでしょ
放っておけばいいんです
お世話にはなっています
が 観察する必要さえないんです
新幹線の車窓から風景を楽しむように生きるんです
全部サッサッサッと消えますからね
ああ いいなと それで十分です
持っていこうと思う必要はないんです
命のネットワーク 無関心な自然よりは
生命は互いに依存し合って協力し合って生きているんです
あの自然は無関心で 生命に対しては
自然から見れば寄生だから
しかし 我々は寄生している生き物は互いに協力し合って生きています
私たちの命を育むために
微生物まで一生懸命頑張っているんです
細胞の中にも入っているんです
入って共存しているんです
それはネットワークなんですね
命っていうのはあまりにも短いんです
この短い間で戦うこと
憎しみ合うこと 自我を張ることをやめて
一切の生命を慈しむんです
ネットワークですからね
これ 慈しみをするんです
辛い人生は楽になります
だから 我々の心に慈悲の気持ちが生まれたら
すごく楽に生きていられます
はい それで終わりです
話は はい どうもありがとうございます
お話お話ありがとうございました
テーラワーダ仏教が重要視する経典というのはどういうものなんでしょうか
もうちょっと  テーラワーダ仏教が重要視する仏教の経典というのは
例えばどういったものなんでしょうか
えーとですね そういう重要する特別な経典はないんです
ブッダの言葉は全部ものすごい重要なんです
だからブッダは無駄話しないということを徹底しています
だから我々が使うパーリ経典のどんな言葉でも
びっくりするほど智慧があるんです
だから我々はあえてこの経典というふうに出さないんです
個人好みで何か学ぶのは
これは一向に構わない
どんなブッダの言葉でも完全に語れていますから
何の損もないんです  先ほどのちょうど例えば御像エクとか
そういったことを深く研究するために
その経典の なんかをお読みになって言われてましたけれども
そういうのは例えばどういったものを読まれているんでしょうか
あ まあその場合はポイント
テーマになりますから
だから区はお釈迦様は初転法輪で発表して
それからいろんなところで項目を解説していくんですね
いろんなところで そういうところ全部調べていって
まあこういうことやっていう風に言ってますけど
例えば渇愛は何やと知りたければ
渇愛について語っている経典
それ全部調べなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうやり方でやっているんです
ありがとうございます
例えばそれはえっと どういう経典になるんですか？ どちら？どんなテーマ？ 渇愛とか
そういったものはこういうどういうものになっている
渇愛で中部経典でマハータンナーサンケスッタという大きな経典がありまして
他のどんなところでもまあダラダラダラダラとあるんですよ
かなり繰り返しリピートしている経典がありますから
すぐ見つかります  あとですね
ブッダの生涯という本をちょっと読んだんですけれども
そのブッダが悟りましたと
菩提樹の下で悟りましたということで
その本の中では そのまあ十二因縁を悟ったとか
そういったこと言われてるんですけども
やっぱりそう ブッダの悟りっていうのはどういったこと？例えばそのブッダの悟りといっても
ノーベル賞を取ったりとか
そういうことじゃないわけじゃないですか
そのまあ おそらく今回考えるのはその道徳的な真理というか
そういったものを悟られたんじゃないかと思うんだけども
その悟りの内容っていうんですね
そのどういったことを悟られたんでしょう
あのね あんたはね なんかちょっとした一部やと思ってるんですね
なんか専門家みたいな感じでね
すべて全体的にわからないで
煩悩が何か分かったっていうね
ではないんです すべて全体的にわかることなの
悟りっていうのは だから学と言うんですね
だから本当のところは
我々知っている世界知識がお釈迦様にはあるかないかわかりませんだけど
全体的に存在とは何かっていうね
物質はどんなものか 存在とは何かということもわかって
で 心からこの苦しみを作る原因もすべて消し去ったというね
いうことで まあ一切智者というんですね
ブッダのことは ああいう特別な専門というわけじゃなくて
お釈迦様もある日こう言うんですよ
あの なんかあの葉っぱが小さい植物
木が植物の森があって
大量に葉っぱがあるんですよ
お釈迦様が森に入って
森ってやっても公園みたいなところですけど
枯れ葉ちょっと手で取ったんですね
枯れ葉手に取って比丘たちに聞くんです
私は手に取っているこの枯れ葉と
この森にある葉っぱと
どちらの方が多いと思う？だが
比丘たちは お釈迦様 これは比較にならんやと
あまりも小さいんだと
手に取っている葉っぱの量は
そう そのように私が知ってる量は
悟りで知った量は この森のすべての葉っぱと同じで
語るのはこの程度だと
なんでこれ語るのかというと
これで人間生命の苦しみがなくなるんだからと
いわゆるいらんことは語ってないと
だから仏教と我々が読むのは
生きる私の苦しみをなくすものになってるんです
が お釈迦様が宇宙の構造もちゃんと知っていて
ダラダラダラ 淡々淡々と時々言ってるんです
で 宇宙は今膨張している
それは仏教ではもう当たり前の話なんです
昔から この太陽の光が届かない宇宙のスペースあるんだというね
仏教ではもうなんて言いますか
ローカンタリカという名前で
ブラックホールのこともあるんです
だからブラックホールっていうのは現代言葉で
まあ昔の人間がね 神話ばっかしの世界でしたから
その人々に理解できるように
まあちらちらと語っているんです
ブッダの時代では この光速
光の速度という概念はなかったんです
そこである日 お釈迦様が宇宙はどれほど広いかということを説明するために
こういう例えをするんですよ
あの 100人ぐらいの力がある人間4人がいるとしましょうと
その4人がある柱に四方八方に向かって立って
弓で100人の力で弓で打つと
例えで考えましょうと
それである人が足が速い人が同じ柱のそばに立ってるんです
この人がこの放した弓をサーッと走って
東西南北走って落ちる前に捕まったとしましょうと
弓っていうのはものすごいスピードですよ
まだ人間に100人分の力があったら
まあそうどうしようもないでしょうに
と言ったら あなたはどう思いますか？と
この男に男の足が速いと思いますか？と言ったら
これはお釈迦様速いでしょうと
で お釈迦様すぐにこう言うんです
これぐらい速さで宇宙を歩いても途中で死にますよと
寿命は耐えませんよということは
だから私は今の現代知識に当てはめてみると
当時では光速とかなんとかという考えがなかったんだから
お釈迦様はこういうわかりやすい例えを使ったんでしょうと
...ということで 宇宙はね
ものすごい拡大膨大であるとも知っていたし
しかし 最近まで地球は平らやと思っていたでしょうに
地球は宇宙のセンターだと思っていたでしょうに
え？センターではないと言った人は殺されたでしょうに
これ 2500年前なんですよ
そういうことで ブッダが悟ったっていうことは
もう完全にすべて知るべきものをすべて知ったっていうことなんです
だから 我々現代人がすごい専門的に考えますけど
あなたもおっしゃっているように道徳的なところではないかというと
道徳っていうのはほんのわずかな一部でしょう
これちっぽけなものをわかったんだからといってね
ブッダとは言えませんよ
そういうことで まあ命に対して
存在に対するすべてをわかったということに発見したということになるんです
はい  どうもありがとうございました
先生 今耳とおっしゃいました
耳とおっしゃいましたが
飛んでいくのは嫌じゃないですか
ん？飛んでいくのは 飛んでいくのは嫌ですね
すいませんでした なんかどこかで間違えました
他にいらっしゃいます
はい  今日はありがとうございました
愛別離苦とか温存エフのこんな深い意味があるとは分からなかったことですから
非常に今日は感銘を受けました
今日の教えというのは
今の日本に非常にこう欲している
みんなが欲しているものじゃないかなというふうに思いますものですから
ぜひ今日の内容を本に出していただきたいんですけども
なんとかお願いできませんでしょうか
それはいろいろ計画立ててやりますからね
今 私個人的にはちょっと約束はできませんだけどね
それなりにみんなに一応手に入るようにするとは思います
これから愛別すること
音声工の解説は 今日初めて皆様の前で発表したんであって
大体仏教を語る人々っていうのは
そこまでは分析しないんです
ですから 他の本を読んでも
一般的な解説以外はいかないんです
ですから このポイントを大事に覚えておいてください
ありがとうございます
では 少し前の方の方で手挙げてください
ありがとうございました
今日の話 日本の仏教界がですね
大乗仏教だと思うんですけれども
そういったこの長老の方から見ると
今の日本の仏教界の姿を見てどうお考えでしょうか
いろんな教典とかっていうのもありまして
私は愛別離苦っていう言葉は知ってたんですけども
ん？ あの愛別離苦  はいはい
日本の仏教界ではこういう認識は全くないんでしょうか
大体仏教の日本仏教だけじゃなくて
自分の国の テーラワーダ仏教の中でもそういうふうに解説しないんですよ
だからお釈迦様のこの謎をかけてますから
そこを解く解くようにまではなんか頑張ってないみたいですね
だから私は皆様方ある程度では透いていると思うし
私も透いていると思いますけど
私は自分で発見しているものはやっぱり素直に聞いていただきますから
まあ私も大変透いていて幸せだと思っています
だからすごい ものすごい大事な
もう宝物の中の宝物の教えっていっぱいあるのに
なかなかもう大乗仏教に関わって限ったものじゃなくてね
なかなかそこまで深く勉強しないんですね
だからそこでまあ上辺だけ取って修行なんかやれちゃっても
そんなにも結果は出てこないんです
特に日本の仏教では 禅
禅仏教ではね この中身に入る入るという努力はすごくあるんです
だからこの経義別伝やというかね
不立文字とかね 言葉様で作っているんだから
経典じゃないよと もうちょっと別やと
だからあの方々はすごい座禅に瞑想に励んでいたんだから
いろいろなんか言葉で言い表せないこの真理の世界がね
もう経験していたと思いますね
だから道元禅禅師も 滝の川の流れがそのものが仏法であってのようではありませんとはっきり書くんだから
これは道元のすごい深い哲学だと言って
もう道元褒めて終わっちゃいますね
これ何言ってるのかっていうことは
禅研究家もわかってないんです
これ教えてあげて怒られちゃったんです
あなたはほとんど読んでないのに調子に乗るなよと
で  50年研究しているんだ
その研究は全部調べているんですかと
私から見れば 50年も同じことを繰り返し研究だから
何の意味がないでしょうにと
例えばね 法華経は何か引用しているのかと数えるんです
仏性という単語は正法言宗で何回使っているのかとかね
道元禅師が引用した経典は何なのかとか
それかす こんなのはもう研究ですかね
そういうことだから まあまあ余計な話になりまして申し訳ないんですけど
まあなかなかブッダの説かれたかったかの本当の心髄っていうのはね
で なかなか出てこなくて
仏教は宗教になってるんだから
その色付きが強くなっちゃって
みんな宗教的な儀式儀礼でもうだいたい終わってしまっちゃうんですね
他のことをやる暇がなくなっちゃうんですね
お経をあげたり いろいろ祝福をしたり
法事に行ったり 葬式に行ったり
もう忙しいんです そういうどうでもいいことに関わってますね
お釈迦様はそういうことはなさらなかったんだからね
葬式にも行かなかったしね
お釈迦様が大事な方はね
お釈迦様の母親とかね
父親とかね そういう場合はもう一応行きましたけど
他は行かないです はい
お話ありがとうございました
えーとですね 愛別離苦
恩情 恩増益ということで
裏の意味を教えてよかったと思いますけども
その表の意味というか
単純に好きな人と別れるとか
ちょっと好きではなくなってしまったので
別れたいという時に そういうことあると思うんですよ
夫婦でも恋人でもそうしたり
正直に相手にも自分にもダメージを与えないでうまくことを別れる
喧嘩しがちですよね 喧嘩して別れがちだと思うので
そういうところをうまく自身の心で別れるためにはどうしたらいいのか
それってまあ答えは簡単です
やって実行はどうかわかりませんだけど
その相手に対して今まであった愛着はなくして
その代わりに憎しみも作らない
これから友達になりましょうよと
で あなたはまあ私の性格悪いんだから
あなたすごい苦労していましたから
大変申し訳ないんだと
では元気で頑張ってくださいと
たまたまね まあ一緒にご飯でもいかがでしょうかという感じで
もう友達で別れるんですよ
だからそれには愛着があるとちょっと難しいんですね
だから友達で別れること
難しい方々はもう愛着があると
次が憎しみが出てくるんです
だから喧嘩で別れちゃうんですね
ですから これをちょっと気をつけて心変えた方がいいんですね
今今までこの人はものすごくいい人だと思っていたんですけど
まあ人っていうのは完全にいいわけじゃないんだと
完全に悪いわけでもないんだと
全部ごちゃ混ぜやと ですから
私はこの人のこういうところ
こういうところ こういうところ好きでした
しかし こういうところ
こういうところ こういうところは気に入らなかったっていうふうに
ちょっと分析してみて
愛着が憎しみに変わらないようにするんです
それでも愛着の方が強いんだったら
ちょっとハイライトするんですよ
この気に入らないところは
こういうところあるんだから
ずっとそれと付き合わなくちゃいけないんだから
やっぱりまあいいや さようならと
はい それから友達で別れることはできます
まあよくね 世の中でね
そういうのはね もう会うことがあったらもう別れたこともあるし
だから私たちがこの一つは調子に乗るんですよ
結婚したところで すぐ調子に乗っちゃう
友達ができたらすぐ調子に乗っちゃうんですね
これが結構知恵が必要なんですね
だから友達で まあ異性でなくてもね
男性の友達になっても
それで永久的に友達っていうことはないんです
毎日毎日 我々はどのように関わるのかということで
友達関係は一個一個築いていくだけなんです
だから決定ってないんです
いつでも壊れるものなんです
世の中では だからそこで結婚しても
まあこの人と一緒に喧嘩しないで
お互いにお互いに心配し合って
補い合って っていうことは毎日の努力なんですよ
そこはとことこと手抜いてしまっちゃいますね
仕事が忙しいとかね 疲れちゃったとかね
私も仕事してるんだから
あんた家のことはあんた勝手に当たり前ではないかとかね
そういう言ってはいけないことを男はよく言うんですよ
女性に向かって 私は金持ってくるんではないかと
これはもう絶対舌を切っても言ってはいけない言葉なんです
これはものすごい間違いなんです
女性から見れば ただ金持ってくるだけで
女性っていうのは生きている世界でいるんだからね
命を育んでいるんだから
命を育む場合は 金なんかは大したファクターじゃないんです
だから金持ってくるんではないではなくて
子供のオムツを変えてくれることにはすごくホッとするんです
お父さんがじゃあ私がやりますとかね
だからこの男性は男性の理論で
なんかすごい この命じゃなくなく
理屈で世界を作ってるんですね
奥さんが家を守って 子供の面倒を見る
私は外に出て仕事をする
はい それでチャラと チャラじゃないんです
チャラにならないんです
だからそういうところも考えた方がいいんじゃないかなとね
夫婦関係に限らず 友達関係にしたっても
会社の人間関係にしたっても
毎日努力しなくちゃいけないんです
すべて無常だから 今までうまくやったんだからといってうまくいかないんですよ
例えば 会社で 10 年間真面目に仕事したっても
一回失敗しただけで もうはい
さようならと言われることもありますからね
ガダフィさんもね  40年間も頑張ったんですけど
もうなんか犬みたいな感じで殺されちゃったんだからね
だから彼が悪ばっかしだったら 40年間もできないでしょ
国民は見事に彼がやったことは全部きれいさっぱり忘れちゃって
じゃあ殺しましょうと
そうなるんですよ それは世の中の常にあることで
だから私たちはやっぱりすべて無常だからね
会社の人間関係も毎日捨ても励むもので
友達の人間関係は毎日捨ても励むもので
夫婦の関係は毎日捨ても励むものであると理解しなくちゃいけないんです
その中でどうしても性格が合わない場合はしっかり理解して
ではもう別れましょうと
苦しむ必要ないんですよ
性格が合わない人と無茶苦労して一緒にいる必要ないんです
まあ大体50パーセント程度で
もうちょっと性格合うならば
その場合 苦労 苦労が少ないでしょ
だから我々は友達作る場合は性格の合う友達を探すんです
結婚するときでも性格の合う人を探すんですよ
だから女性みたいに収入はいくらでしたとかね
それ良くないんです 女性はすぐ現実的にこいつはちゃんとした仕事はあるのかとかね
ちゃんと金持ってくる人間かと
そこを調べるんです だからこれ本能的にやっちゃいますけど
子供もんだから男よりは子供の方が心配なんです
しかし そこは置いといて
子供っていうのはもう自然に育ちますからね
親にお金がなくても大丈夫です
だから性格が合うか合わないかと
それを見なくちゃいけないんですね
性格が合うならばOKと
しかし  100では会いませんよ
みんな個人なんです 百百の性格が合うことはないんです
仏教では模範的にこのサーリプッタ尊者と目連尊者が
もう生まれよりからはものすごい仲良しの友達だと
これはいつでもペアだよと
もうもう別れません もう想像できないほどの仲良し友達なんです
が 性格は違います サーリプッタ尊者が知恵の第一人者で
目連尊者が瞑想の達人なんです
現代風に悪口と言えば
サーリプッタ尊者が知識人で
目連尊者が神秘主義者なんです
合わないでしょ 性格は
それだったら でも すごくこの専門分野が違っただけで
他は全部合ってるんですね
だからお医者さんにはものすごい一番親しい友達として
あの弁護士さんにも友達になれるし
ラーメン屋さんも気に入った友達になれますよ
専門が違いますけどね
そういうことで 我々はこの友達を作る場合は
性格はいくらか合う人を選ばなくちゃいけない
どうしても合わない場合は
お互いに迷惑をかけない目的で
別れな 別れなくちゃいけないんです
で 別れることは人に迷惑をかけない
苦労させないということにしなくちゃいけない
あいつは憎いんだから別れますよではないんです
はい では  元々よろしいでしょうか
じゃあ 今日はどうもありがとうございました
今日にアドバイスがいただきたくて
質問というか 手を挙げました
と 毎日 できるだけたくさんの時間気づいていられるようにという思いがあって
瞑想をしているつもりなんですけど
もっとしっかりやれっていうお答えはわかってはいるんですけれども
意識気づいている時間っていうのが途切れたりとか
すぐどっかに意識が飛んでっちゃったりとかっていうことも自覚をしています
今の私のこの段階で何かアドバイスをいただくことができるとしたら
どんなことなのかと思って質問をさせていただきました
あの理性入れてみるんですよ
例えば家の中でね いろんなことをやっているときは
実況中継やりながら こうだからこうなる
こうだからこうなるとかね
理性を入れてみるんですよ
家の中で歩く瞑想するときでも
足の裏で感覚はそれぞれ違うんですね
だから 床の絨毯の上で歩いているか
畳の上で歩いているかどうかね
その地面の感覚 物質的な変化によって足の裏の変化
感覚も変わると それと同時にあ
認識も変わるんだとかね
で それですごい世界が出てくるんですよ
自分の心っていうのはえらい依存してるものやとね
そういう風にこの実況中継して気づく場合は
理性入れなくちゃいけないんです
理性入れると結構うまくいきます
はい じゃあまた最後の質問にします
後ろの方 今日はどうもありがとうございます
一つ質問なんですけど
実は私の甥がまだ一年生なんですが
小学校一年生なんですけども
学校に行けなくなって引きこもっております
というのは 人間関係とか友達関係ということじゃなくて
歳から歳ぐらいの時に一度お葬式に出席したのがどうも原因になっているようで
それですごく死ということを意識して
自分の母親がいつ死ぬかわからないというんで
すごく怖い もう怖くて家から出立てないような
なんかそういう感覚があるようなんです
それで未だにちょっと学校に行くのも難しい状態なんですけども
こういう大人の説明っていうのは
やっぱり子供にはなんかお母さんはいつまでも元気なわけじゃないんだから
もうちょっと自分で生きていく方法を
やっぱり学校に行きたいって
安定をしたいというふうな説明をすると
かえって今そのお母さんが死んでしまったらどうしようと
そういうところに引っかかっている子ですから
ますます怖さが増してしまうので
子供にはどういうふうに説明して
勇気づけて一歩を踏み出せるようにしてあげたらいいのか
この辺を  あの何歳？ 歳
歳  はい  男の子？ 男の子
お電話です お電話です
お電話です  お電話のね
まああの もっと年上のをね
まあこの自分と同じ年頃も構いませんだけど
まあ自分より年下ので構いませんだけど
いろいろ女性の友達を作ってあげてください
そういう人々のところになんとか友達作って
まあ子供をちょっと預かってくれとかね
年上の  もうでなきゃうまくいかないんですからね
だからいろんな女の人々は
大体子供だから なんとか可愛がってあげたりしますよ
同時に叱るんです これこれちょっとやめてよとかね
これは女性が言うと何のことなく聞くんです
女性にはみんなマインドコントロールされてますからね
人間は  私らからすると
母親に今ぴったりな状態で
母親にくっつきっぱなしで
こう怖くて離れられないような状態
だからそれが問題です
母親にも大きな問題あると思いますよ
だから他は元気で明るくている女の子たちね
大体この子供はいやと思ってる
十八の十八歳の女の子でもいいんです
いやと言ったっても やっぱり見たところでもう本能が湧いてきます
私は一回ホームで見たんですけど
ちっちゃな男の子が子供なんか何かあっち行ったり
こっち見たりとかね なんか迷子になったか
不安になったかどうわかりませんだけど
その子は誰かに助けてほしいんですね
だから コトコトコトと誰にどこにどちらに走るかというと
女の子がいるところに走るんですよ
だから私のところに走ってきたって
私はすぐなんとかしてあげますけど
男のところに来ないし
そこで女の子が二人がまあおそらく十六歳ぐらいやという
もう派手に化粧してオシャレで
もう子供なんか虫みたいな感じで見る年なんですよ
でも子供が困っていたと思うと
ところでお互い女の子の顔を見て困ったなということで
ちゃんとしゃがんで何ですかと聞いたんですよ
結局は だから ああ なるほど
命ってそういうものだな
私はそれで安心しましたけどね
だからいろいろ不安があったり
社会に出る勇気が出なかったりする場合は
あの女の子たちに の中でいた方が元気にはなります
なかなかそういう機会というのが
なかなかそういう機会を使うことが難しいんじゃないかなと思うんですけど
頑張ってくださいよ 子供の子供の命がかかっているんだからね
精神病的になんか私もちょっとお話しかけた時に
心にゾッとするような
お腹の中から寒くなるような
足が震えるような感覚があって
なんとか克服はできたんですけども
すごくそれを  いろいろ言うんだけど
こういうのは私にしても
大体まあ 1 日で治せるぐらいの程度の問題なんです
私はもう日本では難しいんですけど
まあスリランカでこういう子供が何か大変だ
これはなんとか私はまあいいや
もうまあ連れてこいと
で 私はお寺で 1 日一緒に泊まってもらうんです
それで解決します 全部
しかし 寝る時は私と一緒に寝るんです
私は寝るところで寝なさいと
それで朝目が覚めると
子供は何のことなく落ち着いてもう OK なんです
それは男の子でなきゃできませんだけど
で 女の子の問題もね まあ解決方法知ってますけど
やっぱり我々のはエスキモシップは禁止しています
禁じしていますからね
で 私は何もしませんよ
偉そうなことはご飯食べたのかい？とかね
あんた何時に寝るの？とかね
一人で起きられるとかね
そんな程度なんですよ
すごく親切 じゃあ寝ましょうとか寝かせてあげるんです
そこでバリアが破れるんです
心にみんなバリアが作ってますからね
それを破らなくちゃいけないです
だから誰か親以外 誰かと
付き合うことが一番早いと思います
なんとかありますから
そんなのをそんなちょっと調べれば
そういうとこっていくらでもありますからね
で 買い物に連れて行ったり
いろんなところに稽古事をやっているところに連れて行ったりとかね
女性と女の人とは限らず
男の人でも気長にしたら
みんな同じですよ  何とか一緒に思いを合わせてみるのか
そういうふうなことをしてみる
私が言う通りにやってください
あなた方の考えではうまくいかないでしょ
心のバリアを破らなくちゃいけない
精神的な病気だったら
それは医者が判断するでしょうし
ありがとうございます
はい では これでよろしいでしょうか
それでは最後に回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
拍手ください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして平安が得られますように
サッビーティオーイワンジャントゥ
サッブヤローゴーナッサトーマーテーバワットアンテラーヨースキーリーガーユコーババトゥサッブヤマンガランラッカントゥサッブヤデーヴァタサッブヤブッダヌバ
ーヴェーナサッブヤダーマヌバーヴェーナサッブヤサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダー スッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッセニッチャンワッダパチャイノーチャッタローダンマーワッダンティヤーユワンノ
ーสุขンバラン
ではどうもありがとうございます